all right and we are live
the last word with lord condito
anybody's fresh on that friday
morning campfire nice special guest
going on
but first eat what is going on with you
sir how you been man
oh doing all right uh this week of
course in the world of destiny has
always been
mantis i will say the story has been
really intriguing we'll get into that
but e3
yeah yeah that was crazy i knew we
talked about a little bit because we got
the t's and obviously i exploded over
eldon ring uh
we got a little bit more we can kind of
touch on the e3 stuff but it's been
fun just watching the announcements
seeing all the people come together and
fanboys doing stupid stuff
it's it's e3 it's like it kind of feels
a little bit like it's supposed to but
it's um
yeah it's been a fun week just kind of
seeing what info is going to drop but
also seeing how much
you know the past year has affected
everything because we know delays and
people are like what's the release
window oh i don't know a year
like i mean halo still says holiday
because they're like we got to do it but
we haven't put it they put a date on
starfield they didn't put a date on halo
and you're like they they want so it's
just all that stuff going on right now
that's crazy to like
let's read a billion you know let's
write two books over this one thing that
happened so it's like everybody's
reading in deep pretty deep so it's been
a fun week for me but before i go too
deep
uh we got a guest we got an awesome one
joining us today a
very nice gentleman so let's bring him
in as we always do to the campfire here
we go
let's do it welcome to the last word
episode number 154
it's another glorious friday we're back
in front of the campfire for some more
lunar shooter discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest so we're going to get right into
it
i want to introduce a lord whose passion
and consistent commitment to the destiny
franchise
is truly appreciated by every member
within a streaming community
whether it be his amazing race sherpas
or hilarious straightforward style
all done as the titan main we need in
our corner
introducing the creating host of the
jigsaw twitch and youtube channels
the lord of backpack gang amazing thor
interruptions
with the most recognizable titan hammer
in the game
live from cleveland and making his debut
at the campfire of the last
word mommy lord g s
x r clyde how you doing sir best intro
i've ever heard
that's a good one that's how we do it
podcast but uh they got to step the game
up i mean
he can't be you can't be like the rest
of himself
right right right yeah oh and you got a
guest up here we got a cameo here as
well we'll
introduce oh oh camera shy not really
got the dog here too he's not used to
being up this early right
he's like i'm here i'm doing good i'm
doing good no doubt man we got to be fit
right yeah how's your week been cause i
mean i didn't know if you were paying
too much to e3 is anything exciting you
out there what have you been
besides you gotta oh he's ready
that's awesome oh he is now he's here
i had to throw the ball good i had to
talk to all the intro
e3 man uh eldon ring man all about ellen
ring
yes i played dark souls 3 on stream and
fell in love with it
so i'm ready for eldon ray and uh you
know i mean
you know the halo it does look good
battlefield looks good
oh yeah um i mean i'm excited for that
kind of stuff
um busy week
you know just getting ready for uh grand
masters oh yeah i'm actually going on
vacation next week so
oh perfect timing right you're like
alright grandmaster's lunch see ya
yeah yeah grandmasters drop tuesday and
then i go on
vacation to orlando on wednesday so nice
nice nice
that's what's up man yeah man we gotta
get into
history a little bit man oh yeah he's
ready
he's tight he's ready thor's already
thor's
this dog's born for content
or gotta get him like a set armor or
like a thor shirt so it's like
puppy armor
he's got some merch coming oh he's got
the merch coming we got it all decked
out yes he's got some merch coming
that's awesome
so we set up the questions yeah i know i
got a couple for uh
oh no you wanted to go history you can
start yeah let's start with history man
let's start like just gaming in general
before we get into like the content
creator stuff as far as like you know
kind of like the origins for you as far
as like what were some of the first
games just in general that got you into
gaming
man that goes all the way back to
paperboy bro
let's go that's all g talk i was like
how old you just aged this whole podcast
we're here with you we're here with you
but yeah normally we're like
they're like i i started playing games
at halo 2 and you're like go to bed just
no
a lot of nintendo favorite boys super
marios you know
oh gee stuff duck hunt you know yes
that's called
zach don't she like yes
that's great i was definitely like
brought up on on gaming
just because like you know as i wasn't
outside
playing sports i was inside playing
video games you know moved on to the
sega and
which one which the signal okay let's go
okay
sonic and you know mortal kombat and
uh i've over some other i don't even
remember well if you were on sega you
had
you had blood over there yeah yeah
yeah this had the blood that was a big
fighter and then you know i mean i was i
was definitely like you know brought up
pretty well because you know i did i did
my chores i did what i could and you
know i got
nintendo 64 dreamcast i mean i had it
all oh man
i mean i really didn't like get like
serious into it until like playstation
came out you know then the
i remember i used to play jet model
whoa
you know find odd job in a pyramid with
like yeah it's a golden eyes a classic
classic i mean it it was it was you know
uh i remember i was the kid that went to
blockbuster and um
yo yup i would hide the game if i
couldn't run it i would hide it from you
so you couldn't get it yes
you're like okay so here's this one you
know
i'd go back the next day and go on the
movie aisle and grab my game and i
couldn't run the first day you know
so that is such a real og talk
that yeah i was that kid oh no that's
i totally forgot but i did the same
thing like yeah you'd find one you want
to hide or something like that tuck it
behind some
you know classic movie and like another
section come back later
i completely forgot but i'm pretty sure
i did that a couple of times that's
awesome
what it is is about that error because
it it takes me back because again
it was the renting game renting cons
that was a thing like a lot of young
bucks don't know like that was a real
thing
so it was it always sucked when you went
and it was only like one or two copies
of that favorite game that you were
really looking for and it's always out
every time you come there they'd be like
oh this game is out
it's not available or whatever whatever
so to have that joint
like like look at them to the side you
know what i'm saying and then you know
you kind of hide it
so that you come back now i respect that
blockbuster game
earbuds first yeah you're good you're
good no it has no chill
as you see
it's so good we just talked about yours
ready yeah mm-hmm
well yeah i mean that was like going to
blockbuster used to be a thing you'd be
like okay you'd be like okay the parents
are written a movie and i'd dive up into
the game section stuff like that
we got a full guest appearance today
that'll be awesome yeah he goes on he
can co-star today
he's not used to this early stuff
usually this is when i'm taking him on
walks and
uh he's got energy right now he's used
to it
that's okay we roll we roll
return box to see if the movie your game
i wanted would drop
in facts
yeah you're like oh did it just what
just dropped over there i saw somebody
drop something can you check can you
check if it's in
dude i haven't thought about that stuff
in a while oh that was an error that was
an error of gaming
blockbusters were like some were
probably smaller but i
remember the one i went to is like that
was a pretty good sized store they had a
pretty good
spread like blockbuster was making some
money at that point
you want to buy netflix for five million
no we'll pass
yeah yeah that's still that's a bit of a
blunder on somebody's record there
mm-hmm
no i mean history sounds years old as we
are that's pretty much all that pretty
much covers so
no question about it yeah
do what no one's as old as you i'm sure
i got some people in my chat that might
beat you
trust me there's gmd might beat you i
know a couple others might so
yeah um but yeah you started you know
it's like
started playing on playstation stuff
like that so
obviously i know you've gone through you
had a business you like
sold i've kind of remembered in the past
year or so kind of went
basically full time and everything stuff
like that even though you were doing a
lot anyway so what's
you know what prompted you to take that
transition of i'm sorry the dog's
interrupting me
i'm trying to i'm trying to not yell
here but he's going to make me do it
i was like yo excuse me he's like
give me my intro he's like oh this is
what i deal with on stream every day the
dog is built for content but
do i try to shot today
you get scared when i get out of the
chair he's like oh oh oh it's serious
[Laughter]
so you said the question was the
transition from working to
streaming yeah it's like i remember you
were literally saying like you sold your
business and stuff like that kind of
being a big deal and then you went full
this direction so that's a major switch
um we can kind of go through some of the
gaming and stuff but like that's to get
you where you are now so i was kind of
curious
how that went down what did you decide
was it just like community was
successful enough
got away from what you wanted to all
those things
mean i wouldn't put that grind on
anybody
i was i was sleeping two hours a day for
three years straight
wow i was falling asleep at work
i mean i was the boss but still i'm not
kidding i'd sleep in my truck
but uh i would stream 10 12 hours a day
work 10 hours a day
i mean there was just it was just full
grind time for me because i was enjoying
content creation
um i uh
started streaming off of playstation you
know my friends
just told me to hit the playstation
button hit the share button
i didn't know what twitch was i was just
the main reason i started streaming on
twitch was to
be able to have friends in uh chat
because
i have so many players in a playstation
chat you know i think it was eight at
the time
yep no like if you had more than eight
friends that wanted to chit chat or play
we couldn't talk
so i i did the share button and i had
the comments on the screen
you know and uh it was real janky
and um i uh
i was just full send and um i streamed
on the playstation for 11 months before
i even bought a pc because i just wanted
to make sure that it was worth investing
into it
um i started the landscaping business
and i turned it into a landscape design
business
and then i went full general contractor
so i mean it worked out good because i
would
do people's lawn care and then i'd be
like oh hey you know you need other
stuff done you want a fence you want
drywall you want
house for renovations i'll do it all one
thing i didn't do was
uh plumbing and uh electricity because i
didn't want to get shocked and i didn't
want to smell people's poo all day you
know
that is the fair place to draw the line
i respect that yeah that's that's all
right
those are the only two i really didn't
want to mess with but other than that i
you know i was full send
um but yeah that grind you know three
years was just
non-stop grinding and non-stop gaming
and
non-stop streaming and non-stop working
and everyone i would always get that
question i would get constant dms how do
you juggle it i'm like i don't
he's like i'm dying over here i just put
on a good map i was taken
i was you know i was um i was doing the
old
you know caffeine cocktail i used to
call it the uh i wake up in the morning
hit the hit the monster
hit another five-hour energy shot
monster
pre-workout i was the the intake of
caffeine per day was just disgusting i
mean my doctor even told me
to you you gotta chill oh wow blood
pressure yeah yeah you gotta be careful
bro you gotta be careful yeah
so i mean i was i was just constantly
grinding and um
you know i mean i was up for it you know
i was always up for the grind so
um so i was taught you know i
i did eight years marine corps right out
of high school so oh wow
i was i was built on discipline and uh
i i pretty much just just went full send
and uh
of the idea of going full time was
always there but i was scared
of course big decision and in general
contracting was fun but you know
everybody's dad and son and family
members now
slaps a name on the side of a truck and
doing the work now for half the price
and
yeah now you're good you're good yeah
you're good
they're doing the work for half the
price and it's
would you share jesus
it was just annoying it was it was it
was it was really annoying to be in
and i i was getting sick of it um
it's the trade was being ruined in my
opinion
just because well people didn't want to
pay for good work
they wanted these half prices and you
know i would always give the excuse when
i would pitch the
sale to them i'd be like you want to go
to work tomorrow and work for half price
they're like no i'm like well neither do
i
talk about it yeah that's real well i'm
like hey you know that's not me
and uh i've always wanted to get into
real estate because
that's that's that's easy money right
there
i told my chat i said hey you know i
want to go full time
i want to go full send and they said do
it
i sold the business in september wow
well august and then i went full time in
september and i haven't looked back
but a little bit it's just a wild ride
let me
let me let me back here for a second
because you're dropping some gems man
you're driving right terms
and thor definitely agrees about the
gems you're dropping yeah
oh yeah yeah like i mean that's real i
mean because
it's like how do you juggle you know
real life
you know that the the quote unquote you
know steady
job that's like guaranteed income versus
what your passion is right
versus what you really want to do
because some people be like yo i don't
think that's smart
you know what i mean you need to stay
with this established business yeah
that takes a lot of coverage to do that
man so like what was like the thing that
said okay
over besides to your fan base but like
what was the thing that got you over the
top to say you know what
i love this i want to do this full time
i'm willing to take this risk because
i'm not going to let you gloss over that
that's a big deal bro
yeah no no that's that's a huge one
kick them out again because
like i don't sleep i don't sleep so that
dog can eat that's that's what it's all
about right there
mm-hmm it gets more male in the peel box
than i do
[Laughter]
oh that's that i apologize no no
yeah this is dedication to the animal
right here so you guys usually don't see
my huskies because the camera's pointed
that way but yeah every so often
i'll be streaming and one will just come
in and sit down it's just like ryle
and you know raya of the two she'll just
sit down and just stare
yeah and though we'll come in here and
like bop my elbow like if you're holding
the phone you're on the phone he'll bop
the elbow
she will just come in and just like
still don't know me no you're good
i deal with this a lot you are fine i
got you go go
i got i got two huskies they somebody
needs something so you're fair
somebody needs something but yeah the uh
i mean the transition was
um i'll shut up hopefully it's uh
how do i best explain this that's a big
jump man i think
i think with with content creation i
always tell people
i think sometimes like especially now
people go over the top you know
and they expect a lot out of twitch
because it's like oh the affiliate
program and uh
you know i'm gonna get the greatest
setup and
um a lot of people that are like up and
comers or people that just start out
streaming they
invest a lot i mean so some of these
newer streamers got a
banger set up than me and i'm just like
man they're going like full
scent and
i always i always watched twitch
and um stop faking it that's fake
um all i did was close the door
yeah oh no
but i i always told myself like hey i'm
gonna treat my community different
and um just
just keep it real with them keep it a
hundred percent and i i've always been
straightforward um
and i i i'm trying to word this the best
i can
um i'll feel free
i was always just 100 with my community
and i never
ever treated my community as a paycheck
i hate to say it but i see a lot of
students do that
you see them they they literally try and
make their chats feel bad
they encourage people to like fund them
like hey pay my bills
you need to get a job second someone
puts a goal up of donation goal i want
to slap him
just keeping it real that's not that's
not your chats that's not your chat's
job you know don't try and guilt-trip
people to pay your bills
like you know you can't make that jump
yet
and you see that a lot and you know in
the industry
nowadays because it's just people just
oh you know help me help me and
i never would like that i i always told
my chat like
i'll see chad gift and subs and i'll
tell them to stop
they go you guys gotta chill you know or
or if there's a lot of hype i'll do a
giveaway because i'll feel bad you know
but
that little generosity right there of
always giving back
knowing that your community you have
your communities back
and it goes a long way
um my community has done crazy things
broke
records i mean it's well i mean let's be
honest here
you know in in streaming it's there's a
lot of egos
and um you know you gotta prove yourself
and uh i would always just set goals for
myself to do like oh i can do this and i
can do this and that's kind of what i
did going into full time i'm like i i
need to set a goal here
i wouldn't tell chat i would just you
know set set a goal in my mind like
this is what i need and then i'd get
there and then i'd be like all right
time to set the bar i'm just saying
there's no chill with me
it's always gotta better you're gonna do
better as you've said full send all the
time
you gotta go full send all the time and
it's just it's
it's full transparent all the time
have to be honest opinions on everything
can't sugarcoat anything
and you know that works out for me but
um
you know i'm not perfect you know it's
it's you know
yeah i always look at it as it doesn't
matter if people are talking good or bad
about you they're still talking about
them long as they're still talking about
you know and you know i kind of do
i always thought that like man i'm doing
something wrong you know how come i'm
not like
i felt like i was peaked i'm like man
i'm stuck here i'm stuck on this hill
how do i
go full send and you know i was just
like dude
you know most people in that situation
would do something they're not
comfortable with
and or try something different
and me i'm just like you know what i
ain't gonna be fake i'm just gonna
i'm gonna do the content i wanna do
thanks
i'm doing i don't wanna do anything else
and um respect
that's that's kind of when i jumped out
of the uh
service streamer yeah i used to do
back in when i first started streaming i
do 15 raids a day
that's work right there i would i was
working hard
and uh i realized in service streaming
that
if you're not doing what chat wants you
to do they'd leave
yeah they were there to use you and that
was it
and um i got to the point where i'm just
like man
i'm i'm i'm over it yeah i'm like i i
just want to do what i want to do and
everyone told me to
change it up but i just i didn't have
the guts to do it because i was
staring at numbers and worried about
viewer count and worried about growing
and i knew that
if i did raids and i i helped the
community out with with pve
that i would have viewership right and
one day i just was talking to friends
and you know
um i was actually talking to glad and
sweat and all my other buddies i play
with and um they were just like dudes
no balls man just do it just do it make
the jump and
one day i was streaming and i looked at
chat and said i'm done
i'm gonna do what i want to do there you
go and if you guys don't like it leave
we're yeah we're good we're chilling and
we're gonna just make the jump and just
yeah you'll know who's real at that
point too
yeah yeah yeah yeah and that's that's
that's what i always tell people now
it's all about consistency
it's all about you know making a
schedule i get that question all the
time you know hey i want to start
streaming what should i do i always tell
people stream for six months see if you
like it
yeah good point good point it's the
first thing
you know stream for six months see if
you can even handle the schedule
and then work on growing because yeah
you got to see
not to cut you but you're dropping the
gems again because you got to see
if it's really meant for you a lot of
people think they know what they want
and then when you get in the ground of
it like you said
you know you start to figure out what
works for you what doesn't work for you
sometimes you find out some people find
out like yo this ain't for them you know
the same kind of thing and what you said
as far as like the server streaming and
then just saying you know what
you know let me let me do what i want to
do that gives me enjoyment which is
harder because a lot of people
some fans react differently like oh
you're not doing what you you know what
i want and all this other stuff but i
want to shout you out with that and the
other thing i want to show you
entitlement
yes yes absolutely absolutely the other
thing i want to shout you out was just
what you do in the raid community
because i think
that's really cool because i i think i
came across you and people were like yo
like he he always helps out you know
because i remember them days e
you know about them days when you jump
in in the raid and they'd be like yo
no galley know what you call it you
can't rock with me you know
i mean yeah yeah it's like that's a good
kid that's terrible real quick
you got this stuff check your they're
like inspecting your loadouts and
yeah at that point i'm like okay that's
nice man
and shout out to you you'll be like yo
come through they'd be like for real
i'm okay i could oh god yeah i had no
exceptions back in the day
i would take people through i remember i
would take people through like hard mode
rather than machine with blue weapons
they'd have blue sidearms no guns i mean
that that was the thing in d1
uh you know i used to have the uh the
ringers i used to call them the people
that would help me
yeah pretty much off stream i would just
three-man every raid with them because
they'll be like hey this is what it's
like
yeah cause they're getting no help
basically
well i would just tell them like if you
can't three man the raid then you can't
help with raids because people are gonna
die and it's hard mode raid and
content's hard and if they die in hard
mode they're gone we can't res them so
you gotta learn how to club
yeah that's what i would used to do good
point go
for it yeah that's kind of one of those
it is true though it's like some people
will go through and be like hey this is
like the most utter efficient way to do
that you're like here's a somewhat even
a
slightly newer player that's like well i
don't have this how do i do it instead
and they're like uh
i mean that's just some of what i've
been doing lately on like my lost sector
videos
just to say i'm gonna do this without
using a super in an exotic and just
trying to do this with like non-raid
gear and just
be like i want to show someone it's like
you could it's like if i can do it with
this trash load up trust me you can do
it just take the time to learn it and
it's like
the occasional comments you get to be
like i love how you didn't use like
xenophage or anarchy i'm like
that's the point same stuff like that
you're like i don't care what like
you can come in here with basic stuff as
long as you got your like you know
champions taken care of we'll figure it
out so yeah no
i like that i got a shout out to chow
give it right back to you yo bad dude
he said know what to do good credit
score and 50 clicks
no but i mean that's that was that was
the actual that's where lfgs actually
got their bad name
is so many people are worried about lfgs
saying know what to do
have 10 clears on day one you're like
this is this is freaking about this is
stupid so
what's funny is uh you get a warning in
my discord if you make it know what to
do if you do it again we ban you
there you go it's it's tough love it's
tough love with people because i
i always encourage that anyone can play
anyone can do anything you know
i mean the game is kind of transitioned
you know i always give people a hard
time right now like if you don't have
xenophage you don't have anarchy like
you're lazy
we literally have you could farm five
spoils per minute now
with templar farm like get to it go make
groups
and and people are starting to do that
but like you nailed it on the coffin
there like
being able to play without metal weapons
and kill champions because i always talk
about this all the time we've been
shooting champions for two years but
people still don't know how to kill them
like and uh and that and that's what
it's all about but it's just
getting people to try harder yeah yeah
inspiration
absolutely and that's kind of the point
where you do want to say it's like hey
this is
and i'll even say it's like hey this is
something if you don't have it
figure out a way to go get it there's
like 10 youtube guides out there
it's not that bad go find one or two
people
and that is the thing about lfg it's
like it has its sucky points we've all
been through those were you like
yeah this was an absolute trash fire
that's totally fine but then you have
those moments on lfg and you're like
dude that was a really awesome group and
that's like some of those moments where
you still get you know a little bit of
faith renewed in the community you're
like there's some awesome just
random people out there coming in
helping out
and you may know what you're doing but
if you get like surprised that like dude
they were really helpful didn't matter
they were helping somebody else and
you're there and they're like oh this
guy knows what to do it's gonna be even
easier it's like
those are the nice pieces so somebody
comes across you and they're like
dude this guy's just like ultra helpful
doesn't matter there's no question why
your community is what it is that's
that's it that's an easy win i would say
because you did it right you're like
come on just like jump in the backpack
we'll figure it out and that's like the
best mentality to have
i mean it's you know it's tough it's not
always now i always tell people it's um
you know my discord is very helpful it's
one of the most helpful discords out
there
there's you know when there's content
there's anywhere between 40 and 60
plus invoice channels playing it looks
like pc lfg
and it's not just pc players it's
console players and i tell them like
that's a privilege
you know you go on other you go and
other streamers discord and i'm not down
talking anybody
they just don't do it they just they
don't deal with it
if they're in discord they're streaming
if they're not in discord they might be
playing with some friends offline but
that's it like me i'm fully dedicated
i'm i'll be in open voice chats i'll
talk with people
and they're like oh my god this is weird
and but i'm used to it they're not used
to that level
i tell people like look you know you
gotta just just don't be a weirdo
and you can you can enjoy these
privileges but if you act like you know
those those eagle gamers we're just
gonna get you and sasha you know
yo shout out to bionic he's big begging
you up he said clyde helped my son and
me through our very first raid my son
was nine and i wasn't comfortable
exposing him to an lfg
group then clyde offered up his time it
changed our destiny experience more than
i could have imagined
he's got an amazing community yo that's
love right there bro
that's you don't get no better than that
right there yeah the man that man one is
uh
on a pc as well we surprised his son
mason with uh with a pc and he came and
raided with me and sweat and everybody
and we surprised them and
uh wow father-son raids like that like
that's the stuff that goes to the heart
you know you get done you're like oh man
that was so cool and you're like no i'm
i'm touched over here it's like those
yeah cool you know what i like that you
know yeah exactly
bro what do you know i'm in the kitchen
oh god oh
you know what it is like it's it's
there's a joy
in like seeing someone get like that
rare weapon or that rare drop from the
raid and stuff like that
and you see it because they in their
mind they're like yo they've already put
their mind i would never get that no one
raised with me i'm never going to get
that type of stuff and
and you see the joy like when you see
that live drop
and the reaction you don't say like i
don't even get like everything be great
damn i didn't get it
but you're so happy for the person
that's their first time
like it's so cool to see what always is
they get the loot that you want you know
yeah yeah 50 clears later how do you get
history though
this bed holder this bed got vault like
you got you got um
with the class like your first time like
ever right do it do a vault
did you get like a lot of like very high
like i like
you know streamer loot yeah like when
you first started playing
when i first started playing when i
first played d1 my first vlog i got
vex um i didn't know what it was
everyone was mad and then they loaded up
a crota
and um i got the um gala horn to drop
ads
best singers yo and
the fire team left us left me in my
buddy kicked you out
before there's like um they left they
left they're like this noob doesn't
deserve these weapons
so rob rob's my best friend and he's
like hey man just
just shoot the boss with your rocket
i'll solo them and we two manned it
and uh that's what when i seen that like
oh we don't need people on the fire team
you can low man stuff
i'm like ooh okay now i'm intrigued but
uh yeah that
that's how it went it was just people
were just like yo he didn't deserve this
stuff
you know and then i remember before this
was before i started streaming
i would just make lfg posts like um
perfect sword bear one phase guaranteed
and i would get blown up
oh blown up by people because they would
just be like hey this dude says no joke
and i would just join someone's team at
crota and be like hey
shoot him with a rock and we're good to
go but then you'd see the rocket fly by
crota and you'd get your face smashed by
crota like
how do you guys miss a rocket bro i'm
like come on dude
i'm up there standing there trying to
get good and then here comes crow to
just
bonk right on the head bro you know i'm
done
and i'm like you'd be surprised man and
i was just like all right
you know and like that was on you guys
not me
shout out today that was on you guys
don't kick me don't kick me
those are the days bro those are the
days oh man classic but to your poi e
like
i know i know we always have our
contention sometimes just with crota but
i know why you love it too for those
hero moments right like
exactly to carry people and i know i'm
not the biggest crota fan but i do
respect y'all because
i know what it means because those rage
you can carry people yeah like you
really
yep that's part of the way they design
things now
because everybody seems to have to have
a role and it's hard to
it's harder it's not impossible but it
is things have changed a bit to where
i mean granted people still low made
them so you can do it it's not a
question
but the rules have changed up a little
bit as opposed to d1
so no doubt no doubt what else we got
uh on a complete different shift away
from this emotional rollercoaster of
greatness we've been on so far
um when we met this man in person at gcx
and still to this day
uh you look like you're you work out a
little bit so i just wanted to touch on
i
i mean obviously i know you said you
were like marine
obviously so it's kind of been ingrained
a little bit but how how long has
fitness been
part of your journey i mean it looks
like it's kind of part of you but
just still curious how how that's gone
seventh grade wow discipline discipline
uh i got picked on in middle school man
i was the littlest kid in sixth grade
one of them and uh i was the only kid in
sixth grade with a beard
like like i i i [ __ ] you not and you hit
peter make fun of me
people used to make fun of me and i was
bullied um
i would uh i would i would um i would
get called names at the bus stop
my mom spoiled me a lot of my my parents
were separated but my mom spoiled me you
know i had the
had the fresh jordans uh you know
the jinko shorts and let's go
figure t-shirt you know you name it you
know let's get it
i had i had all i had all the designer
clothes and people
you know they just bully me push me in
the mud call me names
and you know um one day i got
i got a mark on my face
and um my dad asked me i went over his
house
and he said what happened i said i'm
getting bullied at school he said you
better stand up for yourself
like i don't want to get in trouble he's
like we can't have that
you know you got to stand up for
yourself i'm like i'm going to get in
trouble
he's like i don't care if you get
suspended you take the hell i'm like all
right
he said it it's real as a real
so i uh
first time i ever stood up for myself i
got a broken ankle
you did oh jesus oh wow
outside the school big bully came up
slammed me on the ground
a leg had my like ankle in his hands and
he sat on my knee and like pulled at the
same time
shattered my ankle i walked five miles
home
with about 20 kids walking behind me
laughing at me while i was crying the
whole way home
but i walked all the way home and uh
bear seen me limping in and she's like
what happened who touched you i'm like i
got bullied
she called this she found the number to
this kid's house
made him come over and apologize like
mama bear wasn't playing that [ __ ]
with a cast just you know i had like an
air cast it wasn't like completely
shattered it was a bad sprain but he's
just sitting there apologizing to me i'm
laughing
i'll never forget that moment so i
healed up and
you know and i just i told myself like
dude this can't happen no more so
stay back school goes healed i went up
and went after that kid like
ralphie on on christmas story i'll tell
you what i jumped on him
i just didn't stop i stood up for myself
and um
put the bully down let's just say he
didn't he didn't bother me no more
and um and i just told myself like you
know what can i do and um
remember seventh grade i'd see the the
pep rally like the you know the football
players that get announced and they'd be
in the gym and
they were like the big deal like oh yeah
they got jerseys and they're getting
announcements and
people are calling out their name and
i'm like i want to do that so i started
playing football what position which was
rocket
i was a linebacker and a fullback makes
sense that makes perfect sense
so i you know like the growth spur i hit
going into
eighth grade was just monumental like it
was it was just insane
um i was i was probably one of the
biggest kids
in middle school uh going into ninth
grade i was 230 pounds
wow yeah i seen it by sophomore year i
was 265.
that's that's that's when i was the
brick house i mean i was
you know i was probably one of the
biggest kids in the state in ohio
um you know with pads on you're lo with
pads on you're looking 300.
so you're just a monster and you know i
would just run people over
yeah i'm sure i was i was really
stupid really disciplined i'd go i'd go
to school at 5 30 in the morning and
start working out
oh wow man i was going it was on that
type of time that was full
yeah and uh senior year i tore my acl
and
lost my scholarship i had a scholarship
to iowa 2005.
if anyone's uh hawkeye's fans there was
a quarterback by the name of
ricky stanzi oh played at iowa
he actually grew up with me and me and
him we're supposed to go play there
together but i'm a buckeye fan but hey
you know i couldn't get into buck
i couldn't get into ohio state but um
but yeah i mean
you know when i when i tore my acl i was
just like damn this sucks
and um yeah i told myself what am i
going to do
yeah you know am i going to go to
college when i get out of school or what
am i going to do work
because i always had a job i've had a
job since i was like 13.
and um doing the old paper route and
worked at wendy's at 15. hello
so i just you know
i was talking to my dad one day and i'm
like hey you know i'm not going to join
the army like you
you know because that's you're pretty
much the the marine handoff
so you know we always had a code aren't
really marines yet
so um i told my dad that uh you know i
was thinking about signing up for the
marine corps and he said hey man go full
send do what you gotta do
sign the papers graduated and two days
later left for paris island and
wow frozen people all over the place
like this man yeah they got
you need a book you need like a what is
it like that's what i'm saying like
every time i tell every time i tell like
the life story people are just like yo
you're just like you got all this stuff
going on and i've you know it's just
it's it's just crazy you know i've done
a lot you know i've
you know i lived it up and i always tell
people this like stop being a gremlin
like i understand you're watching twitch
but like
go out get out go do stuff with your
life like
man like i would go outside the street
lights would come on and my mom would
have to yell at me to get me back inside
i'm like dude enjoy life and you know
even
even when i was growing up like you know
the excitement and the lifestyle i had
like you know i was always around like
you know all the fun stuff and doing
trips and vacations and
you know just doing just doing anything
fun i could possibly do and
um it got to the point where i partied
too hard and that's
kind of where streaming leveled me out
there again i was going i was going a
little too hard
but yeah but with fitness you know it's
just you know i mean we sit in our
chairs a lot
you know you get to the point where
you're sitting in a gaming chair eight
to ten hours a day
preach it brother more and you know i
don't know about you guys but there's
been some times where i like get up and
walk around and sometimes you stand up
too quick you get lightheaded
you know it's real it's kind of telling
yourself like man i'm out of shape you
know so i always tell people like you
know hey
hit the gym a couple days a week you
know i'm i'm even lazy right now i'm
like i'm only doing like four days a
week right now and usually i'm going oh
no oh just the four
only forty four
usually i'm doing like six and uh you
know my diet's more strict and
i'll do like five days then i'll do some
p90x at home because that that stuff is
nuts oh
yeah kick your butt doesn't matter which
one you do but uh
just sweat but i uh i definitely like
chilled out but i mean i've lived that
life to where like i mean i used to
weigh my food count my macros
uh you know i always tell the joke of
i'd watch people eat a cheeseburger
and i would i would drool like i i
wouldn't i'm telling you when you stare
at someone eating food
you know you got a problem i would
literally stare at him i'm like oh that
looks so good and i'm like
i was i was shredding i was like 2 30 i
was like 225 just cut
eight percent body fat just on it
and i was like dude living this life is
just not fun
it's just it's discipline it's
discipline like you know what i'm just
gonna eat what i want to eat
go overboard you know just try and keep
that
that healthy dog going and it's it's
it's been working great but um
just got rid of the coven pouch i'm
still here i'm still i'm still out here
that's kind of the thing like keep keep
yourself like
obviously don't have a cheeseburger
every single day but if you got a
craving every so often the cravings only
going to get worse as you said when
you're staring at people yeah yeah
so it's like if you do satisfy the
craving in small moderation
you you keep your sanity you can get you
can stay healthy that type of it's
it's balance it's like you know if you
want a cookie have one cookie don't buy
the package and eat in the whole thing
in the kitchen like
i mean i've tried everything i've tried
meal plans you know meal services
and it just it just got to the point
where i got bored of those
get tired of it yeah i know i do need to
stop being lazy i would like to do more
meal prep because i mean it's
nothing's nicer than having a meal
already prepped especially for streaming
you just go in the fridge grab the
tupperware warming up you're good to go
but i just
couldn't do that but uh i call my my
mom's my uber eats now
i love about a oh from my mom she lives
down the street
and um there's a um
we have a shared account a shared bank
account just for like certain bills and
stuff and i always
if someone tips me and that's where all
the stream labs
money goes you know how you gotta like
withdraw the deposit and stuff
yeah so i'll throw some money in there
and she'll be like oh you know i gotta i
gotta buy something and i'm like i just
you know
that's your money you know so i help her
out you know help moms out i'm big and
family so
i mean she's my ride-or-die but um
you know she got nosy one day and she's
like clyde i'm looking at all these
ubereats doordash you're spending way
too much money i'm like okay mommy you
might cpa now
she's like why are you spending all this
why are you spending all this money on
this food i'm like
i don't want to cook she's like the
money you're spending
buy the groceries and cook for you i'm
like wait what did you just say mom's
cooking
selling it i'm like you know what buy
your own groceries pay your own bills
tell me how much you need you want to
cook for me so like now she'll just
knock on the door but i'll be here back
chat ubereats is here and she'll just
bring me some monster meal
bye you know you know how mom's cooking
is she's it's not just dinner for me
it's dinner for three yeah
or more yeah you're like you're gonna be
eating on this for a day or two
big dinner fresh salad like and chat's
like
chat's looking at it like you're spoiled
i'm like oh but
you know the ball shot the ball pull
that's fine man salute to you but i'm
glad you mentioned that e because um
you know i know we're moving we're going
along but it's important it's important
with health and i think for us i know e
i salute you because you know we kind of
big trying to get gamers to stay on the
fitness thing because look we love these
games we playing these games for hours
and hours
but at the same time like you said cloud
it's like sitting down
being you know what i'm saying not
moving around just and not getting
outside a lot of guys
not and girls they're not getting
outside and doing anything so you're
just staying stationary so long the
weight comes up that you got the
pandemic
so it's like we always try to put it out
there like for me i know me person i'm
always putting the hashtag health as
well get outside go to the gym
even if you you know whatever the fact
that you're there right oh i always say
that i'm like just go there and walk on
the treadmill you're there
yeah something is better than you yeah
it's like
yeah it's like i teach what uh fitness
kickboxing classes so
i've seen every everybody who walks in
that door is typically afraid to even
walk in the door in the first place
and if they hear something like
kickboxing it's like oh can i even
i'm like i have had a 16 year old and a
75 year old in the same class
trust me like we can make this work i've
had it it's the biggest thing is try and
a lot of people worry when they start
trying to do fitnesses like i don't know
what to do and i was like i guarantee
you if you
ask more people are actually typically
going to be nice about it
helping you it's like see or go look
there's a lot of information out there
and just like but yeah it's like even if
you do 50 of a workout that day like you
wake up on the wrong side of the bed you
feel like crap
50 is held a lot better than nothing so
it's like if it's something
another thing that's too is you know is
the the mental strength
um yes talk about getting out like
working out at home you're still at home
so your body doesn't feel like like it
just doesn't click in your head when
you're out
and you're in the gym you feel more you
know active and i always tell people
that you know and i get that a lot you
know i mean i literally get messages all
the time i'll get a small dm like hey
you know you always tell
people to never surrender you know
that's your that's your saying and i
just started going to the gym and i feel
better thank you
yep and i'm just like absolutely damn i
didn't do anything but that's awesome
like you know cause i'm just i'm just
being me i'm just speaking real
it's not like you know it's not like i'm
i'm doing hey here's your daily
motivation speech for the day you know
what i'm saying
i mean it's i do it like i do it i go
you can go to amazon for that
amazing amazing get you going amazingly
give me hikes
yeah it's all about you know it is
important and that's what people don't
understand because
again if you're in to me i feel like as
a streamer i feel like you should
definitely keep yourself healthy because
you know you need that energy you know
some hot new game comes out there
playing or some new content i mean
there's been times where i've rolled 24
hours straight no problem
but you know yeah that's true except for
that time i did
24 hours of serif towers that was the
roughest time oh god
i don't i don't wish that on anybody
that was that was that was the hardest
one that was tough
snoozing but uh you might you could
literally almost do that falling asleep
probably oh ivy i was i was literally
falling asleep it was
it was tough but like chat was there and
we were vibing and we were talking and
like
chad helped me through that one like the
other 24s i've done
like i've been fine i'm kind of like i
keep the energy going but like
chad was there talking to me you know
people were checking in like hey you
know do you need me to come play or
you know some people would that would
join my fire team
or you know be on the same planet
yeah uh because we were doing seraph
towers they jump and discord and they
talk
you know and they'd be like hey i'm
going to come talk about some topics
they'd keep my energy up against me and
i was like
i was like dude this is rough oh that's
dedication
dedication that's that's the crazy that
that yeah i think hopefully bungie
learned on that one because that was
a special level of torture for some of
you guys i i did not partake too much i
did a few but i was
uh i stepped back a little bit on that
one
nope the door yeah no doubt no doubt
but yeah
i love it you know saying because again
it's not just the physical stuff it's
it's the mental i'm just being there and
just
making you stronger and all that other
good stuff but um yeah man like
great is to read i love this
oh yeah i got stories man not newtonians
no over five years of content creation
i've
i've seen a lot and um i've done a lot
of cool things
i'm waiting for the book man when the
book going dropped i need that
you know what you know i i i i
thought i've thought about i've thought
about i've actually thought about
hiring like a writer someone to write
script
just me just sit there and talk and they
just go to town yeah
bro you just dropped season one like i'm
i'm in i'm like
where's the next one coming bro like
this is fire yeah i mean i could just go
over stuff because they cuz they can
word it so much better than i can i can
tell the story but they can have like
the
you know the hype yeah the ups the downs
and um you know and i've
i've i've wanted to do this stuff and
break into like the
i wanted to break into like the real
life podcast stuff but i just feel like
it's it's tough right now with
your schedule with content you know but
again you got to go full send
yeah no no like i said if it do come out
man like i said you got a lot of stories
but
a lot of stuff to entertain us man it'd
be lit we got to bring the tower talks i
was doing this thing called tower talks
i was doing like q a and doing this
stuff but i was just like yeah
i kind of didn't give it a chance i need
to do it again the chat
everybody brad said yo he waiting right
right
iran's always waiting for it
what we got going on with this game yeah
this whole destiny thing that we played
a little bit
yeah um this well we're coming close to
grand masters those are going to be
starting next week uh we'll cover those
in a bit
but as for the world of the vex network
as you guys can see if you're watching
the video the vex network changed a
little bit
wario seems to have injected it with a
little bit of the
taken flavor and yeah we got some
suspicious characters now hanging out in
the tower and we've got some weird stuff
happening so
cognito i actually wanted to pass it to
you because i know you were chomping at
the absolute bit to try and talk about
what is going on with our characters
in the story so this week was an
interesting one and i know tassie did a
video tassie did an article
like all this stuff is coming coming to
light so what's going on in this world
right now
at least the story sir let's get it
let's get it first of all shout out to
the dude in the chat
because they were clowning me in new red
i'm coming for youtube because y'all
were clowning me
yeah i was saying i was on some
scooby-doo theories and i'm telling
y'all i knew what was going on but this
week
again it's been phenomenal you know i've
been really looking forward to every
week
you you launch the mission you do the
override you do the expunge and you
learn a little bit more right so we're
going through it
and i'm like okay as soon as you get in
there the um expunge you're seeing
taking energy you know thing i'm like
okay
you start learning mythrax starts you
know schooling us about about you know
quaria
so everything's coming together you know
what i mean and then you're starting to
hear
okay they're figuring it out and then at
the end of the mission
accord was like savithorn she played us
all this is crazy
so like this yeah big time big time
player so
now i'm like okay [ __ ] my man osiris is
suss again but
like he comes out he's like yeah so you
know i think we should we should trap
cory we should we should catch it so
mythrax is like hold up like
that's not advising like i i really
don't we should destroy this threat
and osiris would with the sus you know
comments again and just you know we need
to study this
imagine the things we could learn and
all this other stuff so
as that continues then you go back to
the time i believe and then um you speak
with x a little bit more
and then you speak to aikora and
i cora drops the most chilling thing
for all the people who are there with
the osiris is suspect theory
where she's like look you can't trust
anybody she obviously checks laxmi
because she want her make the towel
great again stuff you know checked her
hard
that voicemail was so with that i went
to go check i was allowed to lock him
he's like
and then i was like and then she took
over i was like yo yo
pulled up oh i covered she's like no
we're not gonna be doing these
these wild messages over the loudspeaker
you're gonna stop dividing us we need to
be together
so that part was fire i love that that
that interaction but then
you know osiris i mean uh what you call
cora goes
you know i gotta lock everything down
and you know i can only trust
osiris from now moving forward only
osiris is getting
all the information and that's what he
really gets chilling and then the final
part is if you read the lore entry
and um they talk about a shadowy figure
which appears to be sabbathum and
talking about being in someone's body
and this form is tough to maintain and
everyone um you know trust me but you
know i'm lurking in the wing kind of
thing
and look this season narratively is
shaping up to be one of the best
you know we got to see where this
thing's going to go as far as the reveal
of how when they're going to reveal it
but by by all means it looks like
sabrethoon is
among us most likely my man i don't know
if osiris is dead i don't know
if he's being controlled but something's
going on it was chilling
fantastic writing by the narrative team
i just wanna know what y'all think
because
when i was reading it i was just like oh
they're really confirming now like
they're just
really going as classic full sin with
this
you know saying things so i'll give it
to you man like where are you
at with this lore in the tower they're
singing songs
what's going on you know i i
i'm all about it i'm not like floor
daddy
you know but uh
but um you know i mean this is i always
tell people like this is
this has been anticipated since we
learned that taking king lore you know
we found out that it was
you know orcs and his two and her
two sisters because oryx used to be a
female yes and uh
you know sabathune and zebra wrath and
you know everyone was
all hyped about it and we like wanted to
know like what was so special about them
and you know and and you know we've been
teased with savathun like is it
like because remember when we all saw
the the um the trailer for
shattered throne we thought that was
sabathune yes
like oh who is that what's those nights
like you know so we're all about it but
it just
i i've learned to not get too excited
and this is just me keeping it real
i don't take it with a grain of salt
it's just i'm patiently waiting but
the teasers are just killing me like i
just want to know what's going on
like you know are we going to see
sabathan at the end of this season
you know i wouldn't think this one i
would think going into next season but
you just never know
but you know choreo you know that all
that all that stuff's hype for me
osiris is mad sauce you know but you
know we've
if you pay attention to lore if you've
paid attention to things on the internet
you know there's been some supposed
leaks
that you know this was gonna happen so
um but i i think that's
i think they're getting ready to drop
the pipe bomb on us soon to where
we kind of start to see the story unfold
and that's kind of what i'm hoping for
is
next season you know especially you know
what there's like 70 days left of this
season
when we go into the next season in
august like hopefully
that full ride into which queen
um we just see the lore uncover and uh
i want to see like so much lore which
queen like i
just just i know they want to bring us
the content but like
we need to see the story unfold like why
everything happened like why
everything leading up to this was here
for a reason and uh that you know
when that law unfolds and people make
their videos on all the lore of
got to witch queen and what does it mean
in which queen for the content we're
doing like let's just say we slay
sabathune like
what does that mean like i can't wait to
see it all get explained
and kind of just unfold for us i got to
talk to you because um
you know i know you brought into my
attention quickly so like what about you
and i also wanted to ask you this
because um i've seen this theory too
that what if bungie um is kind of like
throwing a curve ball and maybe like
they try to make it too obvious like
where are you at red herring yeah yeah
yeah like where yeah
uh i mean i didn't believe it well
that's
kind of the whole and like new red
literally said one thing and i was
actually kind of i've been
wondering about that line specifically
because peace of the lord that has been
kind of going around it's like i walked
through the city on broken legs
and he literally said oh cyrus ain't
limping and i was honestly wondering if
that's kind of a metaphorical way to say
i walk through on broken legs as in he's
no longer a guardian he may be like
broken on the inside
um but then you go down it's like who's
limping nobody's limping around the
tower that i know of no major characters
like having issues so it's like is it
broken internally
is it broken mentally um right i was
wondering how that phrasing because it's
set in a very specific way and i was
very curious why it was said that way
um but yeah it's like it's
um does it raise any doubt
for you that like if it's if it's not my
man
oh right is there anyone else you think
these descriptions could fit
person of influence when they look at
them you know they they get the trust of
people
you know is there anything maybe i'm
missing because you know some there are
some theories that say maybe
that bungie is trying to throw the
curveball on us i mean of course they
would want to keep it interesting
so i mean if you surprise you with
something there's little bread crumbs
here
it's like lakshmi and the one would
almost be too obvious she's got her
motivations because
she looked in her future machine she was
scared last time for the red war and it
came true so this time she's looking and
be like
hey the following sus because i saw this
thing and but
there's you know it's completely out of
context you don't know if methorax was
helping
the tower when things go down but she
does see something bad coming
so on her side i don't think her
motivations are bad she's just going
around about it in the wrong way
and she's kind of going for a bit of a
power grab um
as for osiris like a lot of things are
pointing his direction
because he jumped on the chat with you
and mithrax and he's like you got
you got the access to this channel and
like didn't know
so it's like has he been listening to
everything the whole time
uh xrad is mentioning like the crow like
the crow has kind of been under osiris's
tutelage
you got mara who's potentially going to
be that way is that like a ploy for
savathun
to mess with crow maybe turn crow
against her sister if
marisov comes back because there's so
much sitting out in the wings between
the darkness marasov we kind of
you know lost track of the cabal for a
minute this season maybe they'll come
back
it'll yep um and then saint and osiris
are obviously
close and friendly and the power between
those two theoretically could be a lot
so
i mean there's a lot that points to
osiris there does seem to be
um but in turn if they do pull something
i don't know where it's going to come
from
because they're to me there's not like
an obvious other
force that's going to be coming in right
so i mean
the fact that it's just like you know
it's almost too obvious when i core is
like hey i just gave osiris like the
access to the mainframe like
that's a bad that's like hey we're gonna
launch skynet here in about five days so
we're gonna be totally right
right it's like it's heading that
direction it's like this seems bad
since he's already been questionable
it's like you know he kind of lost
you know his ghost so he's no longer a
guardian i i think it was tas he was
doing his video and it was just the idea
of this
shot but it was the idea that like maybe
sabbath obviously couldn't you know
corrupt
osiris while he was a guardian because
the light was there but now that he's
not a guardian or lost his ghost in his
light
he doesn't have the power or the force
to keep sabathun at bay so
you can read a whole lot into all this
and which is where i kind of love this
the most but it's also as
clyde said it's like the tease is
killing me and this is like watching
like two-thirds of a movie and be like
all right come back next year
go again next week yeah like you get
your page in the mail a week and i've
said that probably a little while
i was like but at this point i'm like i
just want to know i want to finish
the book like i want to know what
happens yeah i know the seasonal content
has
and again it's like we're talking about
it every week so it's like it's like a
weekly tv show where it's like
it's in the conversation it's got enough
like there's enough
depth to it that you actually have
something to talk about it's like yeah
i'm just waiting for the next like
story beat to show up from eris at the
tree like that wasn't quite as
intriguing here's a word or something
this time you got actual drama
subterfuge you got a whole bunch of
stuff going on and i love
what their the level that the
storytelling is at right now
i just it i think i'm along for the
journey because like osiris seems like
the obvious choice
the curveball would be fun because
osiris is like the fanboy but i mean
if osiris lost his ghost he's not a
guardian when they do
like whether it's now season 15 witch
queen
somebody i think has got to fall yeah
for the impact of the story
whether some people at first thought it
was going to be zaval and be like that
would be huge but i don't think you can
ever get
rid of lance riddick that would be kind
of that'd be true you lost nathan
fillion please don't get rid of lanceric
as well we got we got one
we got one big voice actor left i will
say shout out this time when you were
listening to icora
the voice actor for her is doing an
extremely good job she's nailing like
the role it's like there's subtle
differences between her and gina taurus
but
no she's she's crushing that role but
i mean i think osiris would be a big
enough character that we've now had
enough interaction with if something
goes down with him
it will have an impact as opposed to say
like lakshmi if she's the
you know if she's actually doing bad
things it's like well yeah she was
around most people didn't know it
wouldn't have the impact so i want the
story to like hit
and i think it's going to take somebody
big to do that so the last one i make
you're on fire you're on fire last what
i make is i think for me for it to hit
really different like would be i think
um shout out to gmd geek he kind of
like he said what if like well if it is
like what if scene 14
find out you know what i'm saying and
it's just like you know like
i want that discovery moment if they
could pull that off
where even if they leave it at a
cliffhanger and then someone catches him
in the act or the transformation or
something like that
i think that could hit different then we
get left off with that type of reveal
and then obviously which queen is coming
and you know hopefully they're taking
queen raid like the potential for story
building
up until like witch queen and and then
after that you know the whole life for
thing
i think this could be they they got
potential to go take a kick vibes even
better if they do it right because i
like this whole deception thing
if they do it right yeah like to what
you said clyde about
more about kind of the motivations of
savithoon a little backstory they've had
these like
inkblot storyboards or however you want
to talk about them a couple of those
last couple seasons we've seen those
moments and i would love to see the way
we saw like
how the fallen saw the traveler i would
love to see
some of that for what savathun has been
kind of seeing and viewing
when we like roll into which queen get
one of those to kind of explain
we already know sabathun's it we know
we're gonna be working on trying to face
her at some point hopefully she's
probably a raid boss that doesn't
it's not a joke but like that kind of
backstory
to give everything even more context her
motivations what she's been doing with
zebra
wrath setting up the dominoes i still
want to know what that line specifically
means
quarry and now which everybody at first
like you know day one of the season
story
oh was that the glimpse aquarium right
before you get kicked out and then now
it's like wario's mention in name you're
like okay
you know and then i noticed like quarry
used to be called quarry a blade
transform if you go like
milan or bi for anything like that and
that was quarry a dreaming mind
which again leads me to like dreaming
city which is where i think like
at some point that cycle the death
battery has to actually get like
finished if nothing else for the
awakened so they can get the hell out of
there
um so i'm wondering if the dreaming city
is involved
yeah the story's not fully complete yet
so like is that going to be next season
is that going to be where that goes to
tie into which queen because if you can
shut down the death battery savathun now
has motivation be like all right i got a
problem
my like worm the hunger is no longer
being satiated
so at that point it's kind of like okay
now seventh three he's gotta do
something about it
i've seen some theory crafting like some
some big tinfoil ideas
that's what people have been saying yeah
so yeah it's like there's
they've set up so much and i'm with you
guys like they've set up so many
different
dangling threads of story at this point
they gotta finish a couple and
the where they are at now they can't
keep leaving us hanging they gotta start
completing some of these sending us in a
direction and it's the time where
everything feels ready
they just got to start delivering and i
think this is perfect so agreed
agreed it's been
i was like it's been an interesting did
you guys do the corrupted mission
not a whole bunch different in there
just mostly looks but when you go in
like you teleport the first time i was
like oh
did you guys get to experience that was
that kind of cool are you guys looking
forward because it says there's seven
and that's the one question it's like
beat the expunge missions well we have
three normal
we have three corrupted likely
there's some other one we don't know
about clyde how you liking the uh
corrupted versions of the expunge
i love sword flying across the whole map
and just skipping the hole
[Laughter]
i mean i guess that's an option
playing the intended way i just the
first time i did the expunge mission i'm
just like i'm going to sword fly this
i'm just going to skip all this
it's fun like every time i do one you
know like
yesterday i uh discovered because you
know we just got these corrupted keys
this week
and um i mean they actually dropped nice
drops
um if you go into your gauntlet and you
upgrade that third node
you can get that gear and you're getting
guns now that have the dual perks on
them
so it's uh
what rolls your phone i switched to my i
switched to my warlock
and um i had to do it all again you got
to do the whole splicer quest again
so i um doing the missions again i'm
like you know what these are just so
nice
um well well developed well mechanics
like these mechanics like we need this
stuff you know i'm sick of seeing moats
god whoever made that moat mechanic fire
em
i'm literally just going to freak out
because it's just like but it's cool to
see different mechanics like running
through the orb and getting the extra
timer and
you know like just seeing all these new
mechanics like the lore is cool for me
but the gameplay is
oh you feel 100 nice for me like i need
to i need to see different content so
these missions are a lot of fun
but uh you know it's definitely what we
need we need a purpose
to do content because that's what
everybody's struggling with right now is
you know why are you playing the game
yeah what about you cub
you know i like it i mean kind of like
similar classes i like the uh the whole
timer mechanic and the other ones to
extend it this one was cool just so
you know you get the whole vibe of the
taking you know what i'm saying involved
i got i got to complain though i i was i
was in my feelings
what happened what's up no i'm saying
why are you complaining
i was in my feelings at the end because
like i kept they kept trolling me and
like
bouncing me off the thing the the the
taking what is it the phalanxes that
they shoot the thing
yeah i was getting mad man cause i would
have them
other than
oh yeah where they basically chop off
your toes did you come like walk over
them and they pull you and
yeah i did that multiple times like four
times yesterday yeah the trolling
i can't avoid this the trolley was in
effect
but now like i said i do like it i
really i like to change the pace of it
and i
i like that they added like triumphs for
like speed runs and stuff like that to
kind of incentivize you
to go in there and stuff like that i
gotta unlock that part though on the um
in the gauntlet that what is it uh
something wire walker
yeah i still don't got that one i gotta
stop playing but to what cloud is saying
like i'm feeling
they brought double rolls back because
i'm trying to um
what is it the the grenade launcher the
kinetic one the ignition code
yep yeah i'm trying to get a little
blinding football
thing going on with spike or something
like that i want that i want um
i'm really feeling grit skipper i mean
i've been i got to be a decent one
it's a solid pulse rifle it's pretty
tight
i like the auto auto chrome rush
i haven't used 720 in a while shout out
to 14 i got some
i got some assistance rampage on it and
it's pretty crazy oh see i have a
gnawing hunger like that and i use that
for
so long so yeah that's a great role for
sustained damage i love that
i slept on 720s i haven't used them in
pve in a long time
but chroma rush feels nice like that's
like portable's real good
yeah i was surprised actually yeah i
agree i've got
i've been hitting with like heating up
and then like um tunnel vision
and some like like halfway decent mod
but if i could get something with like
rampage man yeah i've been waiting on
that
so i've been i've been rocking for this
season there's been a lot of chroma rush
i've been using salvager salvo a lot and
yeah
too good that singer with the mods bro i
love dev singer with the um with the
charger light mod and
ordinance or something it's your
ordinance yeah so you do the god slate
like deficit like
def cigarette is really powerful like
really powerful
i love it right now that's been kind of
like
it's definitely made the made its
appearance now you know yeah it's good
to see i i like when like exotics that
haven't got used in a while
and they have kind of like artifacts
that kind of cater to a specific style
obviously grenade launchers are lit
right now but i'm loving depth singer i
can't take it out of
the heavy slot man i mean for like
regular content no i'm not
i'm from vlog i'm not using dev singer
for the most part but i'm definitely
shout out to the dude yeah asian
audience
won my degree yeah man like you get the
cells on the void splash damage
i've been loving the um the artifact
flows like different little builds and
stuff like that
and energy accelerant stuff like that
i'm just gonna keep screaming let me
unlock more of that artifact
yeah yeah stop charging me every time i
won't change the damn artifact yeah
please just
just open up a little more stuff it's
annoying yes yeah that's just one of
those quality of life things
because i was sitting there in a lost
sector i'm like oh i want to try this
i'm like i gotta
and i haven't even like reset it that
many times i usually never touch it and
can get through most things but it's
just
why do i have to yeah it's like you put
this much time in you push this like
just let me unlock the mods you set them
up before i can't stack too much anyway
so one season i think it was like around
the when we it was the season we got a
press of darkness
yeah i was i was changing artifact mods
around because i was like yo i'm gonna
make builds
got to the point where to me to reset my
artifact there's over a hundred thousand
glimmer
oh god i just kept resetting it so much
i tried mod
see that should just be like free should
be free
and so like now i just i i barely reset
it anymore i mean it's
glimmer's not the problem but it's just
i mean the the artifact this season's
just way too good you know it's
it's you know it's fun breaching clear
is just disgusting
with yeah you can go bridging clear with
anarchy i'll do breach and clear with
salvagers and switch over to xeno and
just melt stuff
that's like always a really good combo
that i'll use because yeah you can hit
if you can stun especially if it's like
an over
unstoppable champion oh god it's over
just salvagers just break them and then
that's what's nice about the unstoppable
grenade launcher too is you don't have
to like aim down sights to proc it you
just swap
yep got that three seconds done yeah so
there's no waiting because a lot of
people
you'd be surprised how many people
struggle with stunning champs you know i
help people with
with ma night falls and gm's
you tell people stun the champ three two
one shoot them and they don't and
you're the last guardian standing you're
like oh man
if you can get through a master lost
sector with overload captains
you'll figure it out because you'll have
to by then
those pistols who get you those guys
they are probably they're my least
favorite like barrier i get
it's like they're kind of annoying if
they if like a servator teleports and
then puts a shield up and you can't see
him it's just frustrating
but the overload captains like if you
look at them funny while they're stunned
they on they're like they're back at it
again they're always done and they start
full auto
yeah you're dead they they absolutely
just
kind of vaporize you it's not even funny
so no doubt
real quick he and clyde i just want to
ask you quick like what's the
what's the load like what's your
loadouts that it's been hard for you
like you've been really getting into a
good pocket with as far as like all
three slots
like what what's been like the the go-to
right now for you let's start collab
my explosive payload firefly fakebringer
yeah
i got one too that uh
that thing's slapping uh i can't wait to
get a time lost
um i i hope these time lost weapons can
run the adept mods because that's going
to be huge
yeah though um that the fate bringer is
just
it feels really good i like the stagger
of explosive payload
um i've always used explosive payload in
end game even on my scout rifles or any
any guns that i use to stun champs
explosive payload's good
or you know if you're in a gm and a
vandals trying to snipe you in a
hobgoblin
that explosive payload kind of stuns
them i've been rocking truth teller
blind i got a blinding aids auto loading
quick draw one
uh just because i just swap it real
quick
that with anarchy so i'm literally just
destroying everything with it
it's um uh i've been i'll tell you what
man i've been having fun with this um
the seasonal fusion rifle
yo i like no composer bro i do and i'll
composer i mean i've been slapping
atheon around with it we've been showing
people how to one phase
because you just need a gun that's just
consistent damage and uh we've been you
know
pretty much been phasing ethiopia we did
we did i've done
a couple one phase runs with for video
testing and then um
some teams have been coming really close
but uh anarchy is just hard for me to
take off
you know it's it's too it's it's my
favorite gun in the game but it's
i don't think the ammo economy needs to
be nerfed because it's just
no it's too much yo i i i'm gonna say
happy with it yeah
like this they give you a lot of anarchy
bro
you can get it up to 31. oh man
i feel like you should only have 12 to
18 shots that's it
anarchy 12 is two clips it makes you
play more consistent like makes you
makes you play you know and it would
give us a reason to run like a odds
like it would it would make you think
more about the game and and what your
choices are on
ammo because i mean
seasons ago it was all about special
finisher special finished or special
finisher we need more special ours and
aggies but now it's just oh i got plenty
heavy
let's just nuke this guy you're right
you're right
that loadout is hold outs good there's
some other ones i haven't tried i
haven't tried the
the crown splitter loadout yet i really
haven't messed with that i've ran it a
couple times but i still can't get a
good roll on that thing
it's it's it's i think the best role i
got right now is relentless whirlpool
oh nice i can't get one with the vorpal
to save my life that's the one you're
looking for and that's awesome
so it's d it's it's decent but um it's
just
you know anarchy is just the play you
know i'll throw on
i'll throw on secession sniper for some
you know
gigs and but um
hold on has been aggie in a while that
feels good yeah i miss izzy i miss izzy
so e what about you what's the loadouts
for you right now that's yeah
yeah i've been doing a lot a lot of
sector grinding so it varies on the
champions that you gotta kill
uh overload yeah i got an explosive
firefly
i got one of those too totally lucky um
i will say if you use
the firefly explosion on a normal enemy
can stun a champion which is kind of
interesting that's actually fun to
notice
um and then just kind of messing around
with the mods like if you stun a
champion
the stunning a champion uh it's like
sundering blaster i'll forget whatever
like because the barriers always have
about somebody around him so if you stun
a barrier champion finally
kills everything around him you're like
oh nice so it's almost got that
group explosion effect yeah okay yeah
that one actually helps if you're
clearing some of those out
yeah fate bringer's been good as i said
like salvagers is hard for me to take
off
yeah i love my grenade launchers after
like after i went through the
mountaintop quest like i'm better at
those than
i was doing uh what was it the expunged
labyrinth and i was
taking out the hobgoblins with the
grenade launcher just bombing
far away just now you're just showing
off but it's just like i mean it's fun
just like yeah just send it all the way
out there and like think and i'm like i
just and people are like dude you got
some even one or two comments were like
those are some good grenade shots i'm
like
a lot of practice um so that's why i was
like i love that
because then i paired that with breech
and clear i can put anything on heavy
it's still legendary it gives me
openness for my exotics so whether it's
xenophage if i'm not trying to go you
know xeno's popular for me just it's
because you know 32 34 shots you know if
you get and i'll run
like scavenger ammo finder double
reserves and just even if famine is on
that seems to help me still get enough
ammo where it's viable
um and just it hits like a truck so yeah
it still gets hot it's still good for
oracle's all that what's the second
exotic heavy or the heavy that you use
outside of xeno
so it's like i try not to use anarchy
because i try not to crutch on it i know
it's good believe me
like i try not to use it mostly because
when i'm making the videos i'm like hey
i know most of you don't have this so
i'm not going to use it if you have it
and it's arc burn
use the damn weapon because it's good
but i try not to um
it'll be anything from he's in vengeance
i got a good roll on that one
um just random legendaries that i'll go
through for heavy curious of the falling
stars
have been fun yeah rockets have been
nice um
whether it's he's in whether it's just
bad omens like depends on the burn is
what i'll switch to
and then like as the burn rotates you're
like hey let me go find like a void
scout rifle there's one you like start
noticing we're sudden setting like
eliminated stuff
vouchsafe is another one the one from um
yeah that's one that's the one i mostly
know about
this yeah and then this season vouchsafe
from um
dreaming city's actually back in bible
so i don't even have one of those again
that's old but yeah i mean it's like i
really if i could use salvagers it's in
there that's like my hardest one to take
off because the chain reaction
with breach and clear just gives me
flexibility on basically everything so
that's my using the mod
to bust out the chain reaction right the
uh energy accelerant
you know i get excited when i see them
all grouped up and i suit the salvo
yeah between that and then you pair that
with firefly
yep they just vaporize a lot yeah so
it's it's fun to see stuff explode and
we got a lot of ways to do that right
now
so yeah
this game um well at this point we are
kind of in the weekly tune in tuesday
for the store tune in for your next
episode of story
and then once you're done with the story
about an hour and a half later then it's
like all right what are you gonna go do
we are kind of at that point for you
know you got the vlog challenges which
are out
um they seem too early for this it's too
early to be at this point it's a tuesday
game
i mean am i like am i wrong though like
am i wrong that's
not wrong i mean i call i called i
called this out i said it was gonna be a
tuesday game before the season dropped
and people thought i was lying
you're right you remember me like i was
like hey we get one weekly mission each
week
going through and then you know you're
gonna have your vlog challenges you're
gonna have your
solstice of here is that what this one
is yeah
uh you're gonna have the you know
seasonal event but i'm like we're
two months from the end of the season
and we are
we're where we are so i mean depending
on how dedicated you are for the
challenges
and then how long the story takes if
there's you know seven expunges we'll
get to week nine and
check out till epilogue depending and
i'm with you it's like there's been
this is where like play what you want to
play has been a great thing for me
because tuesday can still be a destiny
day
i can do a variety on other stuff
variety on other stuff and it's been a
lot healthier so
but yeah vlog challenges started so i
know those were the ones that people
kind of figured out on day one
uh those have been plenty of guides have
been out there i've seen some of those i
went through fallout
once and did a lot of them i would say
the gatekeeper is the hardest
uh the gatekeeper challenge seems to be
with the timing of everything is the
only one we didn't do just
kind of haphazardly trying to get them
done everything else just kind of
happened
even atheon even though i'll take that
back i think we glitched atheon
i don't think he can do that anymore so
those two will probably be hard
challenges
yeah um but then the question is gonna
be you got master difficulty nightfalls
and then grandmaster is coming around
the corner
shout out to gixxer clyde's vacation
because he's gonna be uh taking a
breather
yeah dude i'm missing a lot i'm not even
going to be here
i'm not even going to be here for master
vlog day oh wow
wow i'm i'm i'm going um streamers
streamer's taking a day off now you need
to go once that's okay
on wednesday to sunday to orlando and
then i come back
and then i stream monday to saturday
monday to friday and then i leave
saturday july 3rd for hilton head south
carolina
so doing a five day and a five day so
yeah i'm gonna be gone and miss it and
but uh you know gotta gotta do life
still just a game
nevermind yeah yeah yeah
so yeah i've been i've been pushing the
gm's on people like look
go get your golf balls go get all your
all your stuff you need you know
and there's no there's no excuse for
people not to be 1335
because all the xp you get from the
fortnite book you know
a season challenge you see like
well it originally started with destiny
destiny
bungie actually invented the seasonal
book if you go back to rise of iron
yes that was the first one so all the
other games copy destiny
all these all these books these seasonal
challenges
that was originally started by bungie
so uh yeah it's um
you know it's cool but you know i mean
i'm excited i mean that
you know you get that you get that
seasonal sniper this season you know you
can get the to get the triple tap vorpal
on it and put the
big ones on it that might be cool um i
thought hung jury was cool at first but
then i realized that the 180 scouts are
just rough
yeah yeah yeah yeah hungry not getting
its love
yeah i like the barking and the love not
that great i mean it's good for oracle's
what i mean for
all but i don't really use outside of
certain encounters i don't really use
mine anymore
plug one doing anything for either you
guys
i like the archetype because i knew the
diffusion yeah
i deleted them all
[Laughter]
literally just i'm not a big fusion
person that's why it's funny using all
composure but i just
you know i just literally show people
that it's easy to use because a lot of
people struggle with dps on atheism like
look you just hip fire this thing
that's not bad it's a nice way so i
wanted to ask you as you do a ton of
gm's that is kind of
one thing you're known for where are you
at with gm's
obviously those don't seem to be as much
of a struggle for you you've kind of got
them down to a science
do you think they are do you think
they're in a good spot do you think
they're worth the time you put in would
you like to see them
i'm looking out to like witch queen
obviously nothing's gonna happen too
soon but it's like do you think stuff
like
master difficulty whether it be raids
for time lost weapons from adept mods
um or grand masters now with some of
these coming in do you think they're in
a good spot do you think there could be
more
were you sitting on just the state of
this you know top top tier stuff
um i mean for loot wise it's the best
loot in the game
because you know you can do some grand
masters in you know 12 minutes or less
i mean there's some when you can run sub
10 um
but let's just say an average team's
running 13 14 minutes well you're not
running a trials card in 14 minutes
unless you're on the juice
best loot in the game to get you
upgraded materials get you you know
exotics
spoil you you know i've always said i
hate how exotics are just free in this
game
yeah i'm with you
i trigger chat and delete 10 stack of
golf balls i'll delete 10
and shards i'll be like here you go i'm
donating them to you
into the world i don't do it i don't do
it to flex on them but i just show
people you don't need this stuff i just
lost my vault my vault's currently
sitting at 88.
wow i deleted everything so i'm just
like dude i'm sick of this fear of
missing out
hoarding we don't need it you could play
destiny right now with eight guns or
less
you need all this stuff in your vault
transmog's here you don't need to save
every god roll that oh it could be good
just remember if they make six months
from now
they're gonna make a gun for that meta
so you're gonna get the new version
so you don't need to hoard your stuff
like clean your vault clean your
characters up clean your inventory i
deleted a lot of stuff that i didn't
need
back to the the grand master i i don't
like the artificial difficulty i think
it's annoying
um but i'd rather do i'd rather do like
a grand master
grandmaster is actually easier than like
a master because what if you're doing a
master with like togetherness where you
need to hold each other's hand through
the whole nightfall
and then but like i kind of tell people
like
no matter what gm it is when you're
going in what's going to one-shot you
is there hobgoblins is there splicer
shanks is there vandals like
what's in that nightfall that's gonna
one-shot you so you find out what those
enemies are you stay away from
gladiators stay away from them
you know minotaurs splash damage but it
just gets the point where it's just
really really annoying and um i think
people aren't used to trying
i see a lot of people come in and they
just they we lo we load it up and they
take it as a joke i'm like and the first
thing i say is don't
don't push up there you're gonna die and
they just don't listen and they get
sauced and i'm like
you know hey we're gonna restart well
why i'm like because you didn't listen
we're going to get to the boss you're
going to get dumped you know and uh
you see that a lot it's just it's very
tough
sometimes and um but the artificial
difficulty i'm just not a fan of
um but it needs to
it it technically needs to be there
because we're just so overpowered
i mean look how we dominate these raids
you know day one their struggle
day two everything gets deleted you know
and um just everything falls over we're
just too strong
uh for the meta and it's good to feel
that way but man it's just
the the challenge is just not there with
artificial difficulty in my mind and
that's why i keep telling everybody
you know i i mean i'm true to the game
i've streamed it for over five years
i've played it longer everyone's like oh
master vog is going to be nice it's like
load up a master nightfall and look at
those difficulty those modifiers
yeah that's what you're going to see in
a master vog you know
i i think with the master vog they need
to go smart i think they should put a 10
level cap
so instead of contest we're at 20 20
below i think you should be at 10 below
i think they should make it to where
you're just not
beating the crap out of everything
because i think the way they're going to
structure
vog is you have to do master vog to get
the time lost weapons i don't think
we're going to be able to buy them
yeah that would make sense you're going
to have to do the activity so if we have
to do them make it seem like we're
actually like earning them then to just
you know
you got to be careful saying that word
handout you know oh on twitter
but i mean that's what uh i feel like
i feel like our i don't want to say
generation but it was like
old nintendo games kicked your butt and
they were like 30 minutes long if you
could speedrun them so it's like they
were designed to destroy you to make you
learn
very unforgiving like two lives and you
start like there was no easy match of
those so now it's like you know
same thing that's what you said elden
ring i'm like dude i am so excited
because you know it's punishing
but also the most reward it's like the
biggest rollercoaster because you're
like
i never thought i'd get into that kind
of stuff but i did you know and um
i played dark souls 3 and enjoyed it but
but yeah it's just just content like
that
and um you know back to the grand master
thing it's
you know it's a it's a great it's a
great way i think it's it's cool knowing
what you're grinding for hey this gun's
this week you're grinding that's i
always talk about that like when you
look at your director of the screen
why are you playing the game in crucible
because i want a frozen orbit or you're
grinding gambit because you want to face
a meatball every match and it's the same
map for the last two years you know
i love gambit um but but you're getting
a submachine gun or you're grinding
strikes and you're trying to get the new
gl or you're trying to get a rocket
launcher like
there needs to be reasons why you're
grinding playlists while you're doing
activities
so you know when you go into the nut so
you know when you go into the nightfall
playlist
you're grinding multiple things you know
you're trying to get exotics you're
maybe grinding shards
you're grinding upgrade materials you're
getting golf balls
your legendary's dropping there too for
the strike playlist
and you're getting the weekly cli um
drops
so it's like there's a lot of stuff
going on in there and it's
really good to to play content like that
and and and keep these strike playlists
going because that's how nightfalls were
i mean
i mean i remember i remember back in d1
one of the first nightfalls i did the
archon priest
as soon as you get to the boss we'll see
in orbit boys
yeah because someone would mess up and
so you know i always tell people that
you know
it was always hey let's go hide in the
corner i ain't hiding
let's go shoot stuff let's go
no i'm not gonna go sit in the corner or
uh what was that one um
yup you said for [ __ ] he's firing oh
god just the constant laser beam yeah
the laser beam dude the shanks the arc
shanks
oh here comes the shanks everyone's like
where
spinning around like just you know like
that stuff's exciting
now it's just papa well papa banner
shield
you're just so overpowered for
everything and it's just you know that's
why i tell people i'm like you're
struggling if you're struggling with
with nightfalls just run a titan banner
shield it's the most broken thing in the
game with her says
it just
[Laughter]
you know between that and well i mean
yeah a barrier
champions in front of you and it's
immuning things and you just pop a well
and there's no immune for anything you
just break
everything and bust it now a lot of
people do
stand in wells in a grand master
nightfall thinking that cute little well
is going to save you it does not you
still get two tapped
but but um you know i i think it's good
like i like the grandmaster stuff it's
just we need something new because it's
i think people are starting to get bored
with it there's a lot of people that i
know that just don't even care
doing them like you'd be surprised
that's not a lot of the community does
them
no maybe it's different this season
because they've got
help with the seasonal activities you
know the fortnite book and
they're uh they're able to to do them
now
but um you know we'll see we'll see if
we'll see if the community
wants to keep doing it yeah
interesting i wish we could yeah it's
like i could be very curious when
grandmasters first season to see how
many people because you know like the
dedicated ones
who run them half of the people are on
twitch doing it like helping people
through and that type of stuff and the
ones who get help through
and then master as well as like that's
kind of always the issue is like as you
said the
the one-shot mechanics and stuff like
that the artificial difficulty has
always been something i've struggled
with because even something like a
challenging game like dark souls you get
punished
but you can learn the fight if you like
you know sneeze in your head flinches
out the wrong direction and your head
gets picked off by a sniper that's not
that's not skill at that i could
definitely learn i did nameless with
four flasks
wow yeah so and that was i was dodging
i timed everything i i knew when to not
get greedy
and i knew when to time my damage and i
and i you can do that
in destiny it's just find the loopholes
spam weapons
boom there's there's no you don't get
rewarded for trying
that's how i feel no i mean that's a
good way to phrase that that really is
because
yeah it's that you can't challenge
yourself with like i'm gonna be good at
this game it's like whether it's like
okay well i need heavy ammo to make sure
i get a decent amount of damage what if
heavy ammo doesn't even drop
that's out of your control yeah when
you're not when you're not getting a
heavy drop you're just like oh my god
you're just that's why i
literally just i don't spam it anymore
like i'm i'm killing stuff with
primaries
you know and i i'm never like that i'm
i'm always like yo
make it kill it you know don't shoot
champions with primaries but
now it's just throw an aid reach and
clear it
you know anything with breaching clear
if you hit it if everybody throws nades
at it and you can shoot it with your
primary
he's half dead already so you might as
well just keep that going and save your
heavy
you know but like there's really no
reason to um
i don't really me you know when anne's
came out everyone's like glad running
hands or nans i did every gm
all my helps without ams i probably did
five runs with aeons on
because i was just like you don't need
it you don't need that stuff people just
need to know
hey you know what make sure your right
side matches your left i always tell
people that make sure you got your ammo
finders on your scavengers your reserves
no one pays attention to that by the way
no one pays attention to their mods i
people join me and i'm like your mods
are all jacked yup don't they don't even
they don't care
yeah they don't care that's the intro to
every one of my lost sector videos i'm
like make sure this is covered here's
why
don't forget your mods they deserve they
don't matter their stuff they don't pay
attention to their stats they just don't
care
and i'm just like good point you're like
okay i really am going to be
over carrying you today so here we go
yeah yeah what about you i know you're
like
i know vog obviously dropped you've been
playing that some stuff like that where
are you
is master intriguing to you at all yeah
i mean i want to see what's going on i
mean i always feel like they need to
add the always feel like they need to
add the rewards to match the difficulty
and i want to see
the reason to kind of grind and do the
challenges stuff like you know one of
the cool things from like taking king
and all that good stuff was those
challenge modes was those
harder modes you know i'm saying if
you're gonna put contest mode in
and then after week one we're literally
destroying
every boss then it takes the fun out of
it so they they need that yeah they need
that aspirational content so that
you know the hardcore people who still
want that
challenge that want that grind and then
you get rewarded the depth weapons the
extra little
you know pluses and minuses that let you
you know tweak i love that stuff so i
want them to continue with it i want
them to um
to definitely like go in that direction
especially with raids especially with
raise
because like shout out to back with that
he and my clan and it's like
you know after a while like once like
closeted back once you find
whatever is the cheese the loadout you
are going to
milk it is a joke what we do in the
temple like we we just sit there and
it's just like
we don't even know one spot all right
let's melt them out now like
it gets yeah i mean yeah templary you
know i mean
literally kill him in what four seconds
now yes
it's crazy so that that's why i do want
that i want the adapt kind of stuff i
also and you know i'ma preach this e i
really
miss like looking like a boss like they
need i'm tired of tests having all the
fly stuff
you don't say i i miss age of triumph d1
looks the over the top so reward the
people who's doing that content
so they come through the town because i
remember i was that guy to tell her like
yo
what that person got online i'm gonna
cut you off here
you're saying cater to the hardcore
players because if you're saying that
you'll get roasted by the
new flights you get roasted man
i say this all the time like all this
stuff you know hey if you didn't if you
didn't play this c
if you didn't play three seasons ago you
don't deserve the rock the weapons i
have
you don't deserve to have the mods i
have you know i tweeted the other day
i'm like protective lights for sale
if you don't go buy it oh yeah you don't
if you don't go get protective light
that's on you it's the most broken mod
in the game and it's just you know
and people always say that you know and
and and you know i
i hear that excuse a lot because people
just come in and they go well i didn't
play
i don't have this i don't have this but
nope don't have this gun either
you know and it's just like it's really
tough right now and i'm starting to see
that pattern a lot people are like i
don't have anarchy i don't have this i
don't have this and i'm just like a
templar farm
you gotta hit it now yeah and then two
weeks later they come in a chat and
they're like i still don't have it and
i'm like lazy
being lazy what's it gonna take for me
to do
templar farming on on stream and and
show people hey this is how you can get
you know i'm sitting on i think i'm
sitting on like 940 spoils right now i'm
just stacking mine
i'm trying to see if we can use them for
master if not i'm just going to spend
them all in one day and show chat what
it's like to spend all of them one day
but it's just it's you know it's it's
it's it's tough right now but yeah
well put with your statement to you know
say hey there needs to be a reason
why you're grinding stuff you know um
with that with the ornaments and and um
you know the way we look
and i i i totally agree with that you
know it's um i'm
sticking my titan getting all this rhino
crayon sets you know uh it's it's it's
it's
tough stuff to you know can i look good
not bulky once
right right right you know it's it's i
always say like man that the armor is
just is is on a different level right
now
yeah i missed that but it's
you know with transmog now if we just
get good armor we can put it on and keep
it
you know oh yeah for sure for sure yeah
like as i said all i want
is because at the end of the day i do
miss
you know having to put into work a
little bit to get something because you
feel that sense of accomplishment you
see
like yo i put it at work i remember
again i always tell you you know your
mountaintop story i know you don't like
pvp right
but i remember the mountaintop recluse
meta
and you're like yo i got to get in there
and that's i'm a pvp guy so it really
bothers me that pvp doesn't get that
love
that pve gets to to have that
aspirational content
because it's a whole podcast itself
themselves
but you know what it is because if you
put that one again people who complain
when you put mountain top and recluse in
there we was in them glories we was in
that you know
all day trying such a boring matter it
was it was boring
but it made us at least play pvp it made
us say okay you know what i got
these tracks everybody's got this you
guys you guys see i was smart i was on
asia servers shooting my clan mates got
my i got mine in 20 minutes
so i got my mountain top work smart not
hard
hey that's how we got our swords at d1
you'd rumble with your friends and you
sword held each other
that's what we did and you know and when
we one night i was sitting in discord
i'm like dude you know what i'm gonna
try this let's go
to asian servers let's queue up we're
not in comp we're in quick play we're
not hurting nobody
and we queued up and i'm like standing
alone boys i'm firing a grenade launcher
let's go
i'm doing this man we gonna get this
hustle on right there you gotta get the
hustle going you know
uh yeah yeah no but i feel you there i i
say that all the time i say that like
pvp needs you know there needs to be a
reason to go in comp we need that like
there needs to be more weapons like
bring a 2100 gun back bring a 5500 gun
back
give me a reason to go play pvp because
i'm the same although i have been
enjoying it not getting um
no one's getting frozen but you know but
now it's just you know i just feel like
you
i feel like you're going to 6v6 and just
it's just it's so boring
people use this stupid meta in there you
know the weather horde
the bastions the you know the the
dead man's tail if you use that gun yeah
i literally want to headbutt you i i
can't stand it
just it's i'm telling you you're going
to be lazy
because i used recluse for that whole
meta and i deleted two with almost i
deleted one with over a hundred thousand
kills and the second one i deleted was
like 80 000. the third one i have in my
vault still it's like got 130.
so i've killed a lot of ads with recluse
and when i stopped using recluse my aim
was jacked because you were just used to
just spraying it around you know yeah
so like when people stop using dmt when
they finally uh when they nerf that
i'm gonna laugh yeah like because i was
doing that the other day i was in pvp
and i was i was telling chad i'm like
i'm not going to use a secondary i'm
going to use all kinetic like i'm going
to use all
i was using my uh my igneous hammer but
i'm like i'm just going to use primary i
want to get my primary shots and i was i
was clicking heads but like
i just wish there was a reason to play
better you know a reason to want to get
better at the game
yeah i mean which queen feels like the
time that it is
but hopefully we get those incentives
back because obviously nothing's going
to happen in a season on anything that
dramatic
but that does feel like the time where
pvp does need some love i mean people
say it's like what 600 days since we got
a map and those numbers come up and
every so often you read them and you're
like damn that is a lot like
you see the number and then even gambit
maps has been even longer and we lost
some of those and
i know that doesn't need content yeah
yeah it's been a minute there's been a
minute i'm like shout out to the
fortnight book now apparently that's
going to be a phrase yeah i'm calling
that that's the new giant i never heard
that
but like since not all of that since not
all of the seasonal challenges are
retroactive
i have not touched gambit one time so if
i am gonna do my seasonal challenges i'm
gonna do it when every seasonal
challenge is open so i do it once
because last season
i got all the ranks when it was like
triple into me and then later on it's
like hey now go get 40 invader kills i
was like i'm done
i was so mad that it didn't count
anything else i was just like if you're
gonna put stuff out there
and i put that much time in and zero of
those count you know every so often
you're like you go and you're like oh
man you have three invasion kills cool
like eight in one game and you're like
awesome that meant nothing i was like i
was so i'm like i'm not touching gamut
till that's done
um but going back to what you guys are
saying like having things be rewarding
whether it's the weapons in crucible
whether it's you know nightfalls and
things like that
from here's a question for you is this
one i've always joked about on chat i'm
kind of curious your thoughts for
like gm rewards yeah gm's or masters or
things of that level when you get up to
that level would you
say like armor drops you get armor all
the time especially you're rolling in so
many exotics you don't even know what to
do with them would you like to see to
have a chance for
say legendary armored drop with say 12
like i'm trying to think of things that
are within the game that won't totally
break it but give you a little more
freedom
say wep armor that drops with like 12
energy so you can mess around with a
little bit more mods have a little more
freedom to go
a little deeper or weapons that have
double perks on things
so you have a chance at those other
roles because i know we get a few from
the season pass this time but
would that be something that gives you a
little more or is that even enough for
you to say the juice is worth the
squeeze
incentive to play i'm all about that i'm
all about new stuff yeah like 12 energy
armor stuff like that
you know damn you were good for an hour
um but yeah just
more incentive to play you know i i like
the weapons but we need more
um yeah the the the the the exotic drops
just have to be toned down it's to the
point where it's just like man you just
you just don't
don't need them you know you're deleting
them all ek's golden vault's the prime
example of that
yeah yeah i i did i had about 250
exotics in my vault and i saw them i
just deleted them all i kept like
30 of the best rolls i had like in my
vault right now there's one piece
exotic i use and it's my best roll so if
i'm doing
gm's this season or i'm doing milestones
this season i get a better roll i swap
them out
delete the old one put the new one so
no it's uh but yeah i agree likes
anything to
to give us loot incentive to play i'm
all about it you know and any anything
that's new in the game
you know it just takes it's that easy
it's it's that easy to add something in
the game to give us
the grind and that's why i get so mad
because it's just like
i i get so mad that these these summits
go on
and these these these these creators get
to go i'm not cool enough
wait claudette wait you ain't get the
call they get the draft call
i've never done a summon i've never been
to punji nothing
i'm not cool enough man
chad knows what i'm talking about you
don't see no knee pads here oh
damn oh no
i gotta hit the mic drop you know that
was cold i was cold blood i see what you
did right now
but now it's just like why why don't you
like meet like
you need to speak up about this stuff
like i mean i'm a savage if you present
hey clyde what do you think about this
next season for this this this and this
throw it away start in the trash idea
sucks
you need that if it's shitty
content and it's crap rewards get up
get this crap out of here like you don't
don't waste your time for failure
yeah don't set yourself up for failure
and the opportunities there i just want
to see more reason to play pve and pvp
and not make it like a tuesday game all
right so let me back you up because you
dropping balls right now but
my thing is hypothetically
if clyde got the call and we with the
sandbox team
right and they like yo clyde we want
your feedback
pvp let's start with pvp first you know
what i'm saying
what do we do what suggestions are you
giving the team
let's go i'm sorry i'm trying to keep
the dog quiet
first first thing right off the bat for
pvp uh six new maps minimum
if you could do two people are going to
leave cues and just get the new map then
they're going to get bored of it and
wine on twitter
ryan read it that there's nothing to do
in the game they're bored of the new
maps they're going to crucify it so
bungee can't win that
teeter-totter effect you make these
people happy these people get mad
try and do this same thing fair fair
continue
uh guns only playlist no abilities oh
fire like momentum control teases at
that a little bit
you get some spamming of like jade
rabbits but yeah it's like more
oh that'd be really cool all right i
like that i like one more one more
one more uh first two with five
power me and tokens in um
trials there should be an umbrella
system set up to where i go to interact
with saint 14 and it says you're going
to get a
legacy helmet and a legacy weapon
so i'm not getting old stuff i'm not
just getting new stuff if i want the
igneous hammer
or a titan chess piece or a warlock
chess piece that should be in
it should be an engram um
shut up sorry chad i gotta yell at him
he's just
he's an idiot he doesn't do this usually
he's not
loud until noon and it's 11 a.m for me
um uh but yeah we need more tokens for
that i know everyone says anti-cheap but
no matter what bungie can release the
best anti-cheat they're still gonna be
cheaters guys why because it's money
people are just gonna pay money people
are these cheaters are making thousands
and thousands of dollars every weekend
because the community
likes to do what we call a recov stand
for that stuff
it makes me mad i don't even want to
talk about it right fair enough
enough pvp now come with the summit
coffee coming back around now
what's the three changes you want the
most you're speaking to bungie right now
you have to sub it knee pass off though
bungie right now on pve hard mode raids
no res tokens stop being [ __ ]
sorry well we go home every we've only
had one
hard mode raid in destiny 2 and that is
prestige leviathan
every single container had different
different mechanics support okay we need
that
i used to sit and help people on console
at
throne room prestige leviathan for five
hours straight sometimes you get sauced
yeah i swear there was one raid i was
there for five hours
just in the throne room jesus we need
that
rights went soft so we need that we need
that we need the hard mode raids 100
they need to come back they need to come
back
and it's true form i'm coming in a
minute
um number two um
make light level matter again take the
artifact power away
oh you want it away i want taken clean
grind
i wanted to to make i want to make these
casual crybabies
just tear up i want power level to mean
something i want to launch in the tower
if people look at my power level and
people look at my armor they're
surrounding you
oh how'd you get that how'd you get this
go play fortnite go play minecraft go
somewhere else that artifact reset
honestly every season kind of kills me
especially now because it's only ten
you're like okay so
you know the thing that i was close to
well because yesterday you could do it
now today because it's a new season you
got a little bit of a pinnacle grind to
do again which is
still not sure because they took went
away from like 10 to 50 now we're back
to 10.
but yeah i'm with you it's like the
whole the people
hated forever 29 but i i would almost be
really curious if the more people raided
when you were forever 29 not hardcore
but like it doesn't have to be like
taking king hard for but let's just
remember like
we've been saving programs we've been
saving engrams in our vault
but since d1 so creator jake hit rise of
iron he hit 400 in four hours
because of saving saving stuff in the
vault we're still saving stuff
for d2 we're deleting characters when d2
launched
e2 launched we deleted characters to get
ready for leviathan i made six titans
um and we're still doing it to this day
you delete a character and do
heartbreaker
you keep doing the hawkmoon mission you
get unlimited there's people 13 20.
how do you let that slide whoever's
doing that whoever's
whoever's letting this content slide
fire him sorry that's just how i am
you keep doing your job wrong fire them
say what you said someone else could do
it better fan though that's how i feel
it's it's tough it's tough love
the third change i gotta go get this guy
he's like
i really wanna yell chad because i get
so mad like he doesn't act like this
usually he's chill you're gonna go for a
bite hold it down you
he is thoroughly entertaining this whole
thing right here this is hilarious
i was like yeah because i mean i'll
throw my like my armor out there and
stuff like that like what do you want
pvp first i mean that's your bag that's
what you hope for
like what do you want to see out of that
stuff what do you want to see
i want two things i want them to kind of
go back to like
bungee roots with the halo like as far
as the ranking system and stuff like
that i really want that to matter
you know what i'm saying i definitely
want the aspirational content like the
pinnacle gear stuff like that
you know saying i got to come back give
me a reason to come in but like like i
said they got to put more
modes man it's just again you you need
that variety the reason to keep coming
back you have to
they don't respect pvp honestly it
literally
is like this side thing in the game
right now and it's it's frustrating you
know i'm saying for a person
i still love the one-on-one engagements
you know i'm saying like
i live for that you know what i'm saying
to see what weapons are working for the
matter this season
and the combat you know i mean so i i
like that joint um
other than that i think clive really
said everything i wanted to say i mean
you know the difficulty back light
matter actually
like me you know actually mattering you
know difficult content
with correct rewards don't make me do
yeah i was gonna say the third change
the third change
would just be incentives you know
they're they're nailing on they're
nailing it right now
yeah there's incentives to play the game
there's incentives to grind it's just
you need to keep that going
as long as we got pve content to grind
like incentives
you know light levels mattering you got
your hard mode raids back
just going to keep people consistent on
wanting to play
absolutely and like i said i don't want
to i know we dumping on
the cash a little bit but it's like
again for people to get into the game
you have to have that goal
that hardcore goal to make them a spider
break them out of that comfort zone
because some people just going to stay
in that comfort zone they're never going
to attempt or try different things
so that's why i still feel you need that
stuff and you still got the entry level
stuff for the
you know the new guy that comes in and
stuff like that so they just got to find
that balance i'm not saying it's easy
for bungie to do it
but they still have to respect that
hardcore base i i
completely agree with that i'm always
gonna be there for that yeah i mean i'm
with both of you guys because
i mean you know depending on what you've
come from before the power
the whole power level grind i'm hoping
gets a just some rework
pretty substantially with witch queen
because you know jumping in 10 levels a
season you do the 200
but it's just the fact that like you'll
do an iron banner for pinnacles it's
like it's nice to use because i don't i
haven't cared as much about the pinnacle
grind but also it's
you know get to max power level by doing
basic strikes there's
there needs to be different tiers or
different wards or maybe hitting power
level is not as hard but then if you do
you know your strikes give you a certain
level like armor drops in there dropping
at like you know your 50 stat level
you go do nightfalls you're seeing 60
stats you go crush a grand master you
shouldn't be able to like this is a 70
stat roll you still got the distribute
like
i want to see different tiers of rewards
and stuff in the game as well so it's
like that would yeah what was the whole
what was that pit of heresy you'd beat
the boss and get a 50 step
oh my god i lost my mind every time i
was just
yeah and it put things in there it's
like hey if you solo flawless this you
know dungeon or something like that
you're guaranteed a high roll just like
put those stupid things out there so
like if people want to go for the grind
it gets hard but that's the idea is like
as you guys are saying
the whole power level system at this
point for me it's like that needs some
love however that gets like some change
i'm hoping witch queen because it's not
going to happen in 15
15 is going to be all about cross play
which will be fine open up like
literally anybody and
anybody on the street that's going to be
crazy huge bro that's going to be bigger
so crossplay is going to be huge i'm
waiting for that yeah that's
about my plan i'm struggling i'm
struggling on the controller man
oh dude i'm so bad i played the last of
us too with controller bad dude
i gotta go back home i gotta come back
home baby dude see that's the thing is
i've been playing pc just as long as
like i've been shooting on pc as long as
i've been shooting on console
because like rainbow six on pc stuff
i've been doing that just as long so for
me it's like it's always been the better
way to shoot so it's never been like
i'll get through it but i i suck
but the cool thing is the communities i
just like the communities coming
together everybody
finally you know clans even me and you
he like we you know obviously i've been
backwards yeah i was going to be like
hey do you want to raid and you're like
right because of the yeah so it's like
because like all clyde all my clan was
on xbox right
and then you know e shout out to him
he's like bro you got to hook up
your streaming situation i'm gonna get
you you know a rig and
you know as far as specking it out so i
can you know be a better content creator
so he he did the worst thing ever like
he he hooks me up
and then he's like yo there's no excuse
d2 is free on pc what's up
oh he sets you up i'm like i didn't want
to do it because i knew if i saw 60
frames
oh right so i get it and i'm like oh i'm
leaving my clan i'm over here
i mean i'm playing my clan but i'm
playing pc
primarily so i did that for a whole
season so all my console guys there man
like oh you left us
i'm like you do not understand when you
see
you can't go back to the fog i said i'm
not doing that 30 frames molasses no
more
yeah when i seen when i seen 1440p 144
frames i'm like
lied too
bro i was in the vip section of the club
i was chilling i was like yo i'm over
here y'all
but y'all i was like i can see
everything and then the field of view
you know
i always make the joke i can see my
ankles
okay i can see my ankles now i can see
my titan and my titan's feet but you
know i mean i play on both next-gen
consoles now which
which are nice but it just it's just you
know
i always tell people like there's no
console war there's no who's
you know there's no which is better the
only reason that i like pc
is because
discord makes it easy you know and um
this is a huge topic that i've been
trying to push in my discord lately
because everyone's like clyde you know
did you see discord
he's integrating with playstation and
it's coming to playstation i'm like
guys i've been using discord with
playstation for three years where have
you been
you guys got your 2015 console mics
plugged into your controller still
get yourself a mix amp plug in a wire
and you have all your sound in one
headset and like
i'm actually gonna make like a huge
video on that and show people how to
like take their gaming setup
and teach people how to like get all
their sound
because that's what we're going to be
using for cross play i'm not using
there's no shot i'm using game chat when
i'm
cross play so yeah i need to teach
people how to use discord and everything
and like
it's just it's just huge and just to see
how my community you know sits in this
you know
they they sit in my discord every night
and play together i mean it's
it's it's it's crazy like how they how
they they they
literally just sit in there every day
and play together and it's um
you know that i'm trying to push that on
the console community too so
but i always hey still to this day i
still play on all platforms
i always told told chat hey i know where
i came from
i know i came from console okay you go
back to the hood because don't act don't
act brand new always go back
you better please go back he left me
yes no i always go back i'll be on
straight people will be like why aren't
you playing on console i'm like oh you
probably just missed the raffle
i was literally just doing a playstation
or xbox raid like
you know so when the gm's come out you
know i got no problem with signing on
the console and stuff but uh i'm looking
forward to cross play i think cross play
should me personally i think cross play
should have dropped with beyond light
but um that's just me
not with you i i think uh like i said
you know i'm joking i'm just best oh i
know
well as far as um that i really think
it's going to be huge for the game i i
just all the communities coming together
everybody no one's getting broke apart i
got people still in my clan because now
i came back
to console because okay i got 60 frames
yeah i got fov
on series like okay this is tolerable i
can do destiny now and it was in game
pass which made it really easy so i'm
like all right cool
but as far as like you were saying um
it's like it's gonna be so cool for us
to just rock
and then the only thing now is just okay
what are we gonna use the chat platform
most likely it's gotta be discord
because
mostly everybody on pc's on discord so
let's do that i just want them to if
they could figure out
fully integrating all the way because
like claude said i do not want to do
that
in-game chat no stuff no that's not
really trash quality too
yeah absolutely absolutely but yeah it's
gonna be big it's gonna be big for again
that's the thing i'm looking forward to
the most for sure yeah it's like cross
play next season
and then like which queen so this is
kind of
this that was the wildest
that said it was like
he's spoiled man i gotta play with them
all day that's all right you got an
energetic one
my huskies actually sleep more than they
probably more than people would
go on a nice walk yeah and then he'll
chill out and then he'll
i'll stream later and it'll terrorize me
i was gonna say just to kind of wrap
this thing up um i wanted to ask you
guys
where do you think within the year of
2022
since that's where we know it's kind of
going to be that which queen is going to
fall
and then how do you think that in again
pairs with season 15
obviously you know crossplay is going to
be big hey you and chat you want to play
here's your joint code or however they
do it like that's going to be really
cool figure out discord that's going to
be awesome so 15 will be
obviously the lead in we'll have you
know cross play being big some story but
you know still might feel like a tuesday
thing
i don't expect major stuff in 15.
which queen being as big as it's gonna
be where do you see it fallen
were you hoping for and then obviously
do you think that's gonna be
just you know like a seven month season
ah yeah um
i i'm worried that it's gonna be us five
six seven month season i think witch
queen's gonna drop in february right
around that time
it just it just seems yeah i've been
reading some stuff too hey there's been
links
where people have been talking you know
they're thinking around that that
era so again we can't believe anything
but it makes sense to be around that
time because it is
delayed until 2022. yeah um i really
hope that we don't go through a seven
month season
but uh doesn't matter for me because i
mean it's
you know we'll be grinding no matter
what but um
i think they with them delaying it there
should be another season
in my opinion um or
you need like a banger skip crota if
you're going to bring back these old
raids we need a wrath or a kings ball
we need something to do so legacy
yeah we need something we need something
to do because it's it's the community's
going to fight
and um you know i'm kind of good that
it's doing that because i i am trying to
branch out in variety
so i'm excited to play alden ring in
january so i mean i'm going full send on
launch for that
24 straight so i'm excited for that
stuff
you know but other than that you know i
was looking for god of war
but that got pushed back so but um you
know uh
whatever they throw at us i'm down you
know
people always tell me how do you not get
bored it's a little different i could
just do strikes and talk to chad every
day
so yeah cool but we need content but
um we just got to buckle up and this is
what we were talking about earlier
you need to you need the we need the
juice lore we need the cut scenes that
make it just make us go nuts and talk
about it for a month straight
we need that content and i think i think
they know this they're not stupid
they know know that they're about
you know they're they're on the uh
they're on the stand you know
everybody's watching cross play is gonna
launch and people are gonna go this
isn't enough
what else do you got for us you know um
so i think next season's gonna really
surprise us i'm just
my focus is okay august we know the new
season drops what's it august 24th or
something
yep second something like that um 24th
same day as uh
kind of birds of spirits i was like come
on i'm speaking about yeah
so that's the new season yeah it's
august 24th i just looked
mm-hmm so i'm visiting november
because by november it's like all right
you know september october we enjoyed
the new stuff what do we do in november
to to february
so that's kind of where i'm like worried
yep
so there's gonna be something in there
that we need to pay attention to so when
they drop the road map for the next
season i'm gonna be
kind of focusing on that november
december mark because there's got to be
something in there to make us want to go
as long as they put something in there
we're good to go but um
i'm i'm ready for the ride if we got to
go through a five-month season
i i'm ready no doubt no doubt
yeah no i mean you know kind of similar
i think they're in a tough spot because
we know the delay
for which queen is is 20 22. so
they got to figure it out like how
they're gonna stretch it and i'm i'm
curious to see
the only thing i'm dreading though like
that every other week iron banner flow
that that uh
oh my god you know it's already got
festival of the lost iron banner
trials iron banner trials
exactly like that's that's what but what
i wanted to ask is like i'm probably
going to cut you a little early
but uh destiny said and shout out to
those guys
um it's like i'd like to see another
season i'm like okay
does the focus of another season pull
away from them trying to do witch queen
still because they
are still and that's the question is
like where where does the focus fall
like does one take away from the other
as much as i'm complaining
i will sacrifice one of them every other
week type
iron banner kind of light seasons for
which queen to be fired which queen
needs to be fired this is literally like
let's make a break yeah it's making a
break like taking king level
you know and then also i feel the
perfect marketing
you throw king's fall that season before
you get people
worked up you get the hype going so
maybe that season before
like how they did vogue with this you
throw king's fall back you give the
people the feel now you didn't take king
now take your queens up you do tonight
one thing about munching you know the
marketing trailer is gonna be fired of
course we know the train is gonna be
fine we're gonna be pumped up we're
gonna be hyped
i'm like all right and then you do it
that way but take your time i will
sacrifice
the season before witch queen and take
care play other games like clyde was
saying get
you know i got halo winfield we got a
lot of stuff to play yeah in november we
do got stuff to play and like classic
we'll find things to do
and and my thing you know what they got
to do too if they could keep up
this narrative thing that they're doing
it helps it helps stretch it a little
bit
and we know it's stretch content i you
know say it is
but yeah the the drip the drip content
man i'll get you
yeah and i understand it i know what's
going on you know what i'm saying so
long which queen has to be fire though
it has to
everything's on if it's not i'm scared
yeah
yeah i know no i mean i'm always going
to be true to the game you know
i mean this is so there's been there's
been there's
been talks there's been talks after
lightfall there's still another three
years
so yeah i mean so i mean there's some
things there
but i i think we just need to see
everything that we just talked about we
we we we need to see you know general
improvements of the game
we need to get off this tiger engine
asap oh thank him
i think they i think they're not going
to update the engine until they drop the
old gen consoles though because they
just can't handle them
bro they need to do that we ain't even
saying that for the long time that's
gonna be a one but that but that's gonna
be the make or break
are they gonna invest in the game
because that would be bungie investing
in their game are
if they give us new servers not server
maintenance i don't want to see this
new new engines they give us a new
engine they're pretty much saying hey
we're going all in
we're we're confident in this game
making us money
but if they if they don't do it i'm
scared i'm i'm with you
i want you on that i mean we you've been
preaching that i'll give it back to you
you've been preaching that for the
longest like you would love
that new engine man well yeah it's like
they did the
vault to move stuff out of here we know
the darkness like stripped away these
planets
solar system is not empty we just can't
apparently see it in the game right now
so it's like what's the plan to bring
some of those back like with a season
we have this just big gaping hole of
darkness out there so but yeah i mean
i'm with you guys
it's really it's been performing is poor
performance issues since beyond lights
just been terrible
oh on pc yeah it's been spotty they they
keep mentioning it's like
they can't be kitchen hey it's something
we're working on ever it's like every
time it's like hey we've got a little
more optimization this time yeah since
beyond light it got kind of
kind of screwed because it was like pc
destiny was so
perfectly optimized like it ran amazing
up until beyond light you could tell
people like dude it just runs well you
may not be like whatever your computer
can do figure out the resolution
just smooth now you can have like beast
mode rig and you're still gonna be like
man i'm getting some hiccups like i
should not
not with what i've got so and that's
kind of i mean i got this
i got the stasis monster and it still
drops frames
yeah like that's that's ridiculous so
um yeah like for me witch queen is where
i'm looking because they mentioned at
one point hey we don't want your armor
to be
every year we're gonna renew it well now
you're at the point where armor
seriously doesn't mean squat because if
you've got a decent set of rolls and
you've got
you know now nothing sunset you have no
purpose in me getting armor
so that like that level of change
like you're telling me systematically
armor has to be different otherwise it
it's going to just suck forever that's
how you know transmog what's that
here now you're literally looking at
stats if it's not better than your gear
like if it's not a better rolled stat
for your build you're just bleeding on
yeah you're not keeping anything anymore
and that's why i sauced my vault
just because if it's not benefiting your
stats there's no reason to keep it so
now it's now it's tough to to make stuff
important in the game now
i have a funny feeling last but not
least we're gonna go left but i'm gonna
end up but
i have a funny feeling they gonna have
to bring people are gonna like this but
i got a funny feeling sun setting over
time
i got a funny feeling they gonna try to
sneak it back because they never really
killed it they just said for now we've
listened
it didn't say for now mm-hmm you know
and
you never know it's gonna get to the
point where we you know
we're not gonna value a lot of things
because like you know saying like i was
saying as far as armor and stuff
i always i was surprised they walked
started setting back as much as i didn't
like it i was surprised they walked it
back
so i'm curious because as things goes on
it's going to be they didn't they didn't
know how to get rid of replacing
mountaintop
nope right correct correctly while they
sunset it and then they then they undid
it people cried and
pissed because i literally went and
built a dog
well like i was i got i was like i got
crucified before
and still probably do what if they
sunset anarchy
oh you go in there you be you you're
doing it today
you're doing it it's doing like fighting
today that's my favorite
it's my favorite gun in the game but i'm
cool with it
we're doing it we're doing it like at
this point i'm cool with it
to get thing now that's the thing it's
like i talked to a buddy of mine about
this i played
like d1 with him for years it's like if
you do that level of thing it can't be
like hey here's three exotics
you gotta dump like 30 in with witch
queen and you got to do a lot of weapons
and armor
that type of thing but yeah sun setting
exotics are you telling me like
then you could have like hey this
thing's you know we got a different
variation but they could have
but they have to deliver that's the key
you can't halfway and be like hey here's
three exotics with this one
here's an entire expansion with like 20
weapons and five except that's not gonna
cut it if you try and tease anything
with like sunsetting
big stuff and exotics you have to
deliver what you take out
with fresh because that's the only way
it's fun is if you're going after new
stuff that's the key
i'll get crucified for that that's fine
but i was like listen you've been
consistent you've been dying on that
square i respect it all
my only caveat like i said way back then
and i've been consistent
if we do that right because i'll be low
in my feelings but if we do that
i want my new engine i want old gen
left behind i want that fresh new you
know what i'm saying like how they did
i want d3 so to speak you know what i'm
saying like let's just go
all in and really revamp this job
because we know the hallway is a
limitation
we know they got space issues with this
vault and bringing things back and
taking things out
so no no sun setting and no bigger fault
like
in class 8 with the supplies like you
got to fix these servers you know what
i'm saying like
they i don't know if it's just a
dedicated server issue but look there's
going to be cheating but
in my opinion when when they were with
blizzard i don't remember it being all
that battle that's a lot stricter
platforms
i remember it was it was kind of cool
what what you feel like
you you was good with that or like where
you at in general with the the sun
free to play around the game there you
go
you put free to play in the game it
should be the base game and they
shouldn't be doing any end game content
but you guys got it from
understand i don't like talking about
this because people are like oh you're
just glad
the only reason i don't like talking
about this is because people are like oh
you hate the hustle but you know
i it's recuvs man when there's money
involved i mean these people doing
recovers making three g's a weekend
you know three three g's
doing 100 accounts they're doing 30 a
pop
and you know what their excuse is i
can't get a job you're lazy get a job
stop being a bum i was like if they're
doing that they're working but yeah it's
a different way to do it but yeah yeah
it's just it's you know but i get it you
got you got to respect the hustle but
these people are literally getting paid
to just do whatever they want
so that's what's funding the cheaters i
mean there's all
aaa games have cheaters in them no
matter what of course
there's always going to be some yeah
that was we i mean we said that when
trials
was coming back into destiny 2 like we
did our thursday night crazy podcast
after the 12 or whatever we saw
and we were like hey we need to put a
paywall put it behind the season ever do
something
like do a long that's fine but like
trials
no everything else it should just have a
base game
like base stuff to do and it's just like
hey here's an intro to the game this is
a demo
you know yep and then if you want to run
discounts to you know to people that are
new if they have new accounts if you
want to run hey you're a new account you
know what we're going to give you
both dlcs for you know 10 cheaper i get
that
but you know we talk about this all the
time
i think that i think that's and this is
just me being
me i think that bungie's getting cocky
they're looking at numbers and going
look at all these frida players look at
all these free play players
look at our numbers look at all these
new players that we have we're doing
good
we don't we don't need to we don't need
to give them some outstanding content
but we're doing all right
those numbers don't matter yes they they
help they help get your name out there
meaning player base how many people are
playing every day how many people are
playing at the highs
how many people are playing at the lows
that's what you should worry about but i
get it i i
it's a business model that's the
beginning to 90
of the player base that's not hardcore
the 10 don't pay the bills that's what
it is
so you have to keep the 90 players that
are new
or the casual gamer no and i'm not
talking about the
the you know the redditors that
that that give you that excuse i work 60
hours a week and i got two kids that i'm
married i just don't have time to game
yeah that's a weak excuse right now you
can play two hours a week and be caught
up
yeah like it doesn't take that and
that's kind of the issue too is like as
you're saying how quick can you catch up
if you try
you can get there especially just like
doing one character grind play some
there's enough pinnacles enough
powerfuls
you can be close and you can get to 1310
which is not
going to limit you from very much and
have access to just about everything you
may not be grand mastering
but you're going to see just about
everything else in the game so
yeah they they put that you're only
we're only going up 10 power levels per
season now and what which queen will be
what 200 unless they actually jump the
gun and give us more
yeah but it's it's you know right now
everyone's like
i'm such a low level i'm like okay go
play solo comp for four games and you
get 20 million drops
well and once you do your comp games you
know
if you don't want to play comp just go
do strike playlists you'll be caught up
yeah the grind is there to to be made
it's just you know
and then everyone's like oh what's guns
what should we use
you know which gun should we use what
should we how do we get this how do we
get this how do we get this
how can i get this if you're watching
right now or listening or whatever
and you play this game wait for the
season to drop
get the guns get the mods like
protective light all this stuff that you
missed out on
and then put it down get the guns get
everything you need for the season
put the game down so you're not coming
back next season go oh well i don't have
that gun i don't have that mod
problem solved no no
no i mean i said good job but i get it
yeah yeah i get i get how people are
it's a love hate relationship we're so
passionate about the game we wanted to
do good
but we get mad at the little things you
know hey
okay i can go on and on and on about
this you know the whole excuse is
while we're working from home yeah that
that [ __ ] that's last year bud
we're in 2021 though i'm glad you're
going in on
that come on yeah that's all i'm savage
dude
get your ass to get your ass back to
work i got it
see that's why you ain't getting back
into the summit this is it
i'm just saying man get back to work
let's go out we got
what that's do but i was like for me
that's kind of why it's like whether
it's january february march whatever
q122 is what they're shooting for
i just want it done right because as you
guys have said witch queen really is
kind of
i know it's like make or break make or
break destiny killer make or break make
a we've heard this so many times
and again we know we're gonna play it
but witch queen does feel like a time
they need to deliver on some of these
bigger changes
that the community has been asking for
for a very very long time now pvp
has to get love if you see witch queen
and there's no pvp maps people are going
to lose their ever loving mind
if armor is still stale
like it's it's a big it is big so we
will be very curious to see i do want to
respect your time you got a dog that is
going to literally
he won't rip your arm off but yeah you
guys can have fun um
i kind of figured this seems like a
reason to me that's all right forces me
to play with him this is what he does
that's hilarious
you're
yeah all right let's wrap this thing up
this has been an amazing chat
chat you guys have been amazing sir
clyde you guys have been amazing
so at this point the floor is yours let
them know where to find you what you got
going you got any spicy stuff cooking
like
this is the time just tell them where to
find you what you're doing and what they
can look forward to with you besides
obviously if you made it this far in the
podcast
yep oh everything's everything's uh gsxr
clyde
twitter tiktok instagram
my discord it's even discord gg slash
jigsaw and youtube
uh which i'm here every day pretty much
except for the upcoming stuff because i
i'm taking vacation but uh
always fun vibes um trying to push the
youtube more
i've been uploading every day just
shorts you know slashing algorithms
yeah doing the clyde's corners and stuff
but uh yeah i'm just gonna be vibing and
playing the games with peeps um upcoming
stuff
uh we got a little destiny fashion show
going on right now so that's gonna be
later today
uh if you posted my discord a screenshot
of your guardian we're gonna pick some
winners
there's actually a fashion show fashion
show section
but when i go live we're going to do
some judging and hand out some prizes
other than that upcoming stuff just
master vog
helps grandmaster helps and um maybe
throw some variety gaming in there
um but yeah i mean you need a cool place
to chill [ __ ] or free zone
no doubt that's why we like to call it
[ __ ] free and uh
you know you want to see me yell at
trolls and
roast people all day you know where to
find me i appreciate coming on the show
no bs in the world of clyde keep it keep
it keep it real shoot it
that boy shoots straight all the time
like he ain't playing i shoot
i shoot straight all the time man i you
know i'm i'm definitely not filtered
um i guess i go straight for the kill
man that's just me
we gotta get you on this i'm still we'll
put my vote in but we're trying to get
them to reset and make you get back into
the sub
ah no no no no i just do it as a meme
man
you got you want to know something real
savage you ain't ready for this let's go
uh-oh
i dm'ed them and asked them why i didn't
get an invite
you pulled up hold up i pulled i pulled
up i pulled up man
yo what's good what's going on i said yo
what's good you got something against me
or something did i do something wrong
just let me know now so i can go full
savage mode
and they're like nah they're like nah
you're good they're just you know we had
we had some tough choices and yeah and i
was like okay
communication i'm like just letting you
know
i was about to go ape [ __ ] see
it's good see you you had it cocked in
the chamber you was ready to shoot
that's what i tell people man like you
want something you go get it so
i'm savage man i keep it real but that's
why a lot of people
watch the channel and that's why a lot
of people hang out because i just keep
it real and
i don't sugarcoat anything disrespectful
but but
i do you know like bionic said in chat
earlier we played this kid
if i got to tone it down to pg i can go
full pg
um you know i respect family and kids
and stuff
you know absolutely no doubt we just we
just like to have fun
try and just i try and just be a leader
of the community and um
but i can but no one's perfect oh of
course not oh brother
salute just be you what about you cog i
think you were busy last week so you
might just need to sleep
yeah yeah sleep sleep deprived but uh
first again shout out to clyde for
pulling up uh
tremendous story again i'm waiting for
the book yeah
i want to get something going yeah first
in line but yeah one thing i got to
shout him out he always shoot himself
and i love what he does for the race
sherpa community and just making people
feel welcome
because that's one of the hardest things
in destiny to get into it you know a lot
of people tell me even
i'll dm i mean i'll tweet you there's
people that'll hit me up like yo i'm
trying to get into the game i don't know
what to do
and they're intimidated let's be honest
they're intimidated they're overwhelmed
but when oh yeah yeah when you create a
community like how you're doing like how
he's doing
i love it and it's accepting it's
inclusive everybody gets a chance to
rock so salute to you guys on that
and uh yeah man you know finally winding
down the e3 stuff we had some big shows
you know with the with xbox and
playstation and stuff like that this
week we'll just do like an aftermath
show so pull up my law podcast every
sunday
the lord's day 1 p.m eastern i think
we're gonna have jazz corner for windows
central
awesome and rand outdoor we'll be back
so we'll we'll talk about the latest
gaming
news what's going on and um yeah man of
course that last world
podcast with the cheetah my man he
bought this you're saying
another fire episode always fun to do
this show and i love
you know what i'm saying to see
everybody pull up and just talk game and
have fun with it but
yeah that's what i got what you got
going on e uh
first shout out to thor for running that
household fan fantastic to have the
cameo today is
so great uh clyde man thank you i'm glad
we were able to make this work i mean
you know
met so long ago i got to be on the
podcast with you a while back actually
and it's like had a blast and just loved
your energy the real
and you brought it today and it's like
absolute pleasure having you on
and you brought your time to bring it
i'm running on two hours right now no no
you're great
and shout out to chat and your community
who showed up today you guys are all
fantastic so thank you guys so for
everybody who hears this sees this or
otherwise please go follow chicks or
clyde
um everywhere amazing content and also
please
go follow iron lord's podcast they are
blowing up they're doing special stuff
guys so go follow both of these amazing
gentlemen
and all the stuff they're doing because
yeah they're you weren't we're in good
company today and chat
you guys have been on fire somebody said
something about larry what is that
what's the larry check what's that oh
boy all right
let's do it we got to get the final
final pen in here
give us the final chapter on the book
he's trying to push the dog out
he's pushing you want to kick all right
so the way larry checks work
all right chad so this is what this is
something new a lot of people lurk in
streamers chats
they don't know what to say i just say
the word larry and that's how powerful
it is because they're already typing
so a lot of people lurk a lot of people
lurk in twitch chats
yeah i understand how important it is to
talk
to a lurker i've had people come up
and say hey clyde love your content
hey
chad is doing a bazillion ones if you
guys aren't in here live
i'm wait i'm waiting to get this story
i'm trying i'm trying the dogs really
[ __ ] me
you're good you're good you're good
[Laughter]
this is worth the ask right here i don't
know what's happening but the build up
the anticipation
it's real this is live at the table
right here
well some sometimes people are new to
the channel and they just don't know
what to say they don't
know how to like type in a streamer's
chat so
i found a way to get them to talk so
who is is you know we start talking
about the word larry and people start
freaking it out but you know i got this
little
little animation to wake them up you
know we clap their hands
warm it up
you're watching ibana's stream writing
you probably don't know what to say
you might be new here this is your time
if you type one in the chat right now
it's like saying hi to all three of us
i'm waving back
i hope you're having a great day what
you don't realize though is you're
getting baited into talking in chat
yeah it's all good yes sometimes you can
be like hey
streamer how's your day did this today i
got this going on this week
it's really easy really easy to talk and
chat but
we see you love the larry's
hello salute i love the engagement
that's larry's
larry check it out one it up let it up
put it one stop shoulder what's up
that's awesome that's the larry check
that it works and they are literally all
coming through
that is awesome you doing what you're
doing brother we like we like it you got
a great community keep it up brother
well that has been an amazing episode
thank you all very much we are going to
go
blow up uh there's not a ton of people
streaming destiny this morning but
at least in my world i got what do you
guys think pigeon or zoe i'm torn both
across the pond
pigeon zoe or ob katy cat i got all
three and they're all across the pond so
you guys got a thought or a vote we'll
raid them right after we wrap this thing
up
but today thank you guys very much this
episode has been fantastic clyde
sir it was an absolute pleasure um
so for this episode for the dog yeah
thor
shout out thor you get some extra treats
today double walk whatever you earned
you've got a club
for june 18th episode number 154 it's
been an awesome chat learned a lot about
this man go hang out with him he is
legit thank you guys very much for this
episode it has been
last word